[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is kevin rose welcome to the
tim tim show otherwise known as the
random show kevin rose i have him here
how are you sir dude you sound just like
me you said that you said you're kevin
rose
i'm stoked man we're back back doing the
random show again this is uh this is
gonna be one that i hope i can make it
through if you make it to the end of
that vomiting onto the screen we will
consider it at least a success and we
require i think some context for people
listening
got a text from you about 45 minutes ago
asking if we might be able to reschedule
what are the reasons for that not to
name any any people's names but we can
talk about yeah compounds okay compounds
so you and i we we tend to i mean you're
the one that got me into this stuff it's
really your fault a dubious dubious
honor
you you got me into the whole scene of
trying out these different compounds and
and seeing what happens on the body and
actually you know what it's it's a
really good thing it's a good story
because
i am going to hopefully live longer not
that i want to have my main uh i don't
want to live forever i'm not one of
those people that is like you know
waiting for the flipping to happen where
ai takes over and we just live forever
like i don't care about that but i want
to have a good long healthy life for my
little girls right so i pay close
attention to all the different
biomarkers and one of the things that
has always been an issue for me
has been glucose disposal so
you and i we sit next to each other i
don't actually i don't know how you're
let's just say a healthy person i don't
know how your glucose levels are i know
you used to eat all those bear claws so
that's true you do love the bear claws
so yeah
the the issue i have is is if i sit down
next to a healthy person we both eat the
exact same carbohydrate if we're wearing
a continuous glucose monitor i will
spike higher and the glucose will stay
elevated in my blood longer than most
people that's not good you don't want
elevated glucose levels it's what they
would call like close to a pre-diabetic
so you know i just need to watch that
stuff pretty carefully
cardiovascular exercise is huge high
intensity interval training zone 2
training all that stuff is really
helpful
but there are also some compounds that
you can take
that help here so
one of them is called a zympic which is
this subcutaneous shot that you do so
you just shoot yourself anywhere you
want i just do it my belly
and
it lowers your glucose levels it's
pretty amazing it just works really well
and actually the some of the other
benefits it's been shown in studies to
be cardio protective
so
a physician that i work with actually
prescribed it to me
and they said hey the one thing you may
want to worry about like it can cause a
little bit of nausea in some people and
so i'm like i'm like okay like you know
and they're like you may want to ramp
this up right so
the the little like syringe thing that
it comes with you can twist the little
knob and you can choose how much you
want to inject and like
i had a buddy that was doing it too and
he's like okay just do 0.25 for like
four weeks and then you can work up to
0.5 and then eventually one milligram
and i'm like
well all the benefits and i should say
another benefit is that the the number
one side effect is that people lose
weight as well so like you lose like
your beer gut you get slimmer you have
better glucose control i mean it sounds
like a win-win-win across the board
until it comes down to the bombing side
except for
the misery the long and lean misery yes
you know i just kind of jumped to staff
like yesterday
you know i had a couple beers and i'm
like you know i just should just go in
because like i just don't want this to
go straight to my gut i love that it's
combined just i want to juxtapose here
this is worth highlighting after a few
beers
first of all i live in portland oregon
best breweries out here it is very
harder than summertime i've been there's
been a major heat wave here tim
and i
better stay hydrated with that alcohol
stay hydrated
no but there's a lot of jokes aside uh
thankfully we got through the heatwave
and it is the the beers here are
phenomenal so
i it was fourth of july you know there
was a lot of fun stuff happening so
basically
i just go into the you know
where the
fridge is and i pulled it out of the
fridge and i inject myself and i turn to
0.5 right away i'm like i'm gonna skip
that .25 stuff let's just like jump into
the benefits right so i did it and i
felt fine i was like you know no big
deal waited an hour two hours everything
was fine
went to bed
woke up at about 4 00 a.m just
wanting to vomit
just
just so bad and just i i haven't laid on
the ground of my bathroom in a very long
time maybe since when i was doing my old
dignation podcast like like 15 years ago
or something
but it was it was yeah it was not good
so
i just kind of stayed in bed this
morning called off a couple of my
meetings and
you made a good suggestion on something
that decreases nausea i did that and
here we are good to go
good old zofran it helps yeah
also really important side note uh
generally when people use something like
ketamine in a clinic they'll give you
zofran beforehand so it uh it doesn't
work
oh that's right because ketamine causes
a little bit of nausea as well at the
higher doses right it can it can yeah
very different purposes as far as i know
ketamine will not give you a six-pack
yeah but do you have glucose issues
uh not really not right so you're just
like you wake up in the morning if you
were to test yourself you're like 75 80
85 kind of thing i would have to take a
look i mean you have to keep in mind
also i haven't worn a continuous glucose
monitor since
check this out two thousand eight or two
thousand you're missing out that was gen
one
dexcom
you could not get it unless you are a
type one diabetic
and the insertion procedure is terrible
and the device itself you had to track
the readout on a proprietary device
there is no integration with anything
like a smartphone or an iphone
and it was really
helpful
i will say that most of the takeaways
were pretty straightforward yeah like
yeah when you eat a huge meal even if it
is quote unquote good food
you really have this gigantic bolus of
sort of carbohydrate intake even if it
isn't carbohydrate really high protein
still spikes
so most of it was kind of self-evident
and after a few weeks i was like i think
i have a pretty good read on what my
triggers are including foods that i
respond to strangely so i didn't feel
the need to wear it
continuously past a few weeks oh man i
remember when we went to the movies and
you first had that thing on
and i you had this i mean back then it
was massive
you had this massive like third party
like like
pd like like a a little mini tablet with
your whatever those little device was
yeah yeah and i was like looked like a
pager that was on yeah like a huge bit
i'm like what are you doing like no one
had ever i'd never heard of those
devices before a long time ago and
you're right the procedure back then was
this massive needle they would even hide
it they didn't put it behind any like
you know thick plastic so you wouldn't
see it like you would watch the needle
go in and inject another little thing
into you and then you would have to
mainly pull the needle out it was
so brutally invasive and now oh dude you
got to try the new ones they're amazing
you don't even know what's happening i
actually have a new one i haven't put it
in yet okay cool but the old dexcom if
someone can think of like a barbecue
kind of two-timed pitchfork
that you use to like flip
steaks or something
it kind of looks like a miniature
version of that it was two long prongs
that were
kind of like needles that you would have
to push into your abdomen
laterally
right and there was no spring loaded it
wasn't like like today you push a button
it's one press button and you pull it
off and it's done yeah none of that yeah
so
uh one of many things i did for the four
hour body
so are you planning on continuing to
take
what is the name of the drug again
how do you spell that uh
google ozempic
[Laughter]
[Music]
o-z-e-m-p-i-c i believe
something like that yeah o-z-e-m-p-i
we are not recommending that you use
these people just oh i mean you'd have
to get a prescription from your doctor
but yeah
yeah yeah so i i here's the deal like i
i feel that um well we can say it
because atiya has had a podcast on this
compound and a couple other glucose
controlling compounds yeah are you
talking about foreman i am not taking
metformin i think that
well i mean the thing is like you tim
it's like we we just have to listen to
the scientists and what they're saying
and that for me is all the the
scientists and people analysts that
atiya trains are works with and and and
it is uh a company so
um they look at that and say yeah there
is a benefit for people with type 2
diabetes
uh but it's not necessarily clear if you
don't have diabetes if there's a health
benefit there so i think it's it's too
early
you know you're talking about beer
consumption
just to talk about the putting
life in your years instead of yours in
your life side of the equation
uh
can i share with you an alcoholic
beverage that i become quite fond of yes
this is new for me so here is the
problem uh one problem that i have
is i don't drink beer it just does not
really affect my system very well
so what ends up happening is i'll go out
with someone like you and you'll be like
yeah let's have some beers
i don't really have beer okay what do
you want i'll have gin and soda and then
we're going kind of gin and soda for one
beer gin and soda for one beer which
ends in tears yes oh that's the worst
yeah it ends really really poorly
and then i was approached by this
company
to sponsor the podcast and i'd never
heard of them june shine
and june shine makes hard kombucha had
not heard of them but i was like okay
well i like kombucha i do in fact enjoy
alcohol even though it's fallen out of
fashion when people are like i only use
ketamine i'm so evolved i'm like well we
should talk about that but some people
say when people say that you at parties
yeah
ketamine i don't use alcohol
yeah that's that's turned into this
substitute for alcohol which you know
may or may not have a place but
suffice to say i don't have ketamine in
my house for a lot of reasons uh we
could get into those
uh has a place but
i will have
this right here this june shine and yeah
comes with many different players yeah
it's great and so i reached out to my
team to ask them about the company and
uh one of them was like oh yeah i know
children i have three boxes of it right
next to me
and i thought to myself well okay that
tells me something because my team i
consider to have very good taste not
literally although they might have that
too
and it's great because it's carbonated
it has i believe
six percent
alcohol by volume
and you can get a nice buzz from one
because it's highly carbonated and
certainly also has alcohol
and i just don't seem to have the
hangover nor the losing arms race of
doing like gin and sodas per each other
person's beer it's been really nice so
this has turned into more of a
recreational
light alcoholic beverage for me
i'm a huge fan yeah i didn't the one
thing i was curious about is what how
much sugar were i always see these types
of beverages at the store like these
hard kombuchas or the hard seltzers all
that stuff you know yeah and i hadn't
tried that white claw before but i tried
it for the first time have you tried the
white claw
the white claw i haven't tried the white
cloth it's like the facebook
the way to claw
i haven't but how did you feel after
that it's not that good it's not that
good it's i get why it's it's like i
don't know i feel like when we were
growing up it was um what was the hot
thing like the wine coolers it's
essentially kind of like a wine cooler
type style
oh my gosh that's the first alcohol i
ever got drunk off of sema that's so
funny
but yeah 3.6 grams of sugar that's not
so bad i'm looking at uh at their site
right now yeah yeah it's uh it's it's
allowed me to be socially
to socially drink alcohol without just
crucifying my brain cells
and i've really enjoyed it you want to
see a bad decision you want to i can
share a bad decision with you yeah okay
a bad decision is this mug i'm going to
show you this is a mug that i bought
some time ago as a gift for my
girlfriend and as context just so people
don't
lose their minds completely
my girlfriend will often text me various
things like
calm down sugar tits she calls me sugar
tits for reasons that are unclear to me
but sometimes she'll call me sugar tits
so i thought it would be very funny when
i was
walking through this random store and i
saw some people chuckling at a mug and
so i bought this mug i'm going to show
it to you first can you see what this
says yes it's calm your tits calm it
says calm your tits
and uh it has two little dots in the o
and the u of your so you can imagine
that and then
lo and behold
uh we end up
uh reuniting because we were traveling
separately
and in between the time that i bought
this and had like put it aside for her
in a place where i knew she would find
it
the day before we were to meet up we got
into this huge fight
and so then the next day
i somewhat forget about this gift and
she thought you put that out there
well i did put it up there but it was
two weeks earlier no i know but
everything was groovy
and uh so then she pulled it out and
she's like calm your tits hmm
thank you babe and i was like oh oh i'm
in trouble
i'm getting pulled into the deep water
oh i did this to myself
uh i feel like she would find that funny
under normal circumstances under normal
circumstances she would have found it
hilarious but the fact that we had a
heightened
let's call it a a heated a passionate
discussion within 24 hours that had not
yet been fully resolved
uh led to calm your tits not being as
funny as that yeah that's fair so good
decision bad decision
what else do we have
on the roster oh man lots of stuff to
talk about we got a lot yeah i mean you
know one of the things we can we did put
a little tweet asking for people's
questions lots of questions around
blockchain and t's all that crazy stuff
we can save that for later
and we can go and stay on the health
front you want to do that or do you want
to go into some of the blockchain stuff
up to you
you know since since i will be mostly
just staring at you with a blank
expression once we get to all the
technical
details of crypto and blockchain i'd say
let's stick with health for a little bit
yeah yeah so i'm curious what actually
you know looking at the video now we're
going to put this video out or no it'll
be video as well yeah why not yeah so
you got a little like device up above
your
door frame behind you
yeah that little guy right there yeah so
one of the questions that i had for you
actually is like you know we're not as
young as we used to be
and uh
for me flexibility has been such an
important thing to focus on and
flexibility with supporting muscles to
so that when you do get flexible you're
just not just like a blob
um and i'm curious like you know i saw
that machine hanging behind you is that
for flexibility what do you do like
what's your focus these days on the
training side are you in court as you're
getting older are you incorporating more
around like the
not not longevity but more around just
less mass and more just you know
practical
like old people stretching like what are
you doing
watching a lot of richard simmons videos
yeah exactly
i am
uh
so for people who can't see this there
is a pull-up bar within the door jams
behind me and so the design is such that
as you pull down on it
the physics of the engineering cause it
to sort of buckle outwards without
damaging the inside of the door frame so
it's a cool design it's a really elegant
design you can find them on amazon
and
i use that for hanging
and really just decompressing or
compressing depending on how you look at
it
my back scapula
and
uh
also just relieving my lower back and
hip flexors from sitting for too long
period of time
my priorities from a training
perspective right now i would say i can
just lay it out pretty simply would be
conventional weight training once or
twice a week probably no more than that
it's really to maintain muscle mass
perhaps build a bit of muscle mass and
also
to make it a little easier to maintain
healthy glucose levels right so if you
are increasing your muscular mass
particularly if you're doing these
workouts prior to a meal your glucose
disposal is just going to be
improved like yeah glute 4 transporters
and so on will
simply be be more
effective at doing their job
so let's say once or twice a week on on
top of that right now my activities are
kind of seasonal these days and they're
seasonal in part because i really want
to identify
types of exercise that not only i enjoy
but that i can do with my girlfriend
and that's actually byproduct of a
conversation at one point with an
incredible
trainer
performance coach
and all-around hilarious guy named kelly
starrett who's a beast like when he
turned i think when he turned 40
he celebrated by running the quad dipsy
which is an ultra marathon
by the way he weighs like 220 or 230
pounds he's extremely muscular
doing a standing back flip and like
cleaning and jerking 350 pounds or
something like that that's how he
celebrated his 40th birthday just to
give you an idea for this guys it's a
party yeah it's a party and
uh great great guy
the ready state you can look him up uh
kelly starred
and he was telling me about how
he has prioritized activities with his
wife over everything else he's like once
you have kids
you've got a family you've got business
demands
anything that you choose outside of that
is pulling you away from time with your
wife or your family and so he's really
tried to prioritize that
and before i have kids i'm hoping to
develop some of those habits so for
instance rock climbing is something that
i'm doing more and more and absolutely
love
for
basically everything that involves
pulling you're going to check the box
and uh i really really enjoy it it's
very
cognitively challenging too i mean it's
like putting together
like an upside down
tetris yeah i mean well they call them
they literally call them problems right
if you're bouldering they they're called
problems because sit there and spend 15
minutes thinking about what you can do
before you even attempt it you know yeah
exactly exactly i really enjoy that
and so we'll we'll go to the climbing
gym two or three times a week usually
the lifting will happen
after the climbing in the same gym
kettlebell swings once or twice a week
i'm gonna get around to answering your
macro question
these are all
mostly strength and
muscle mass focused
but
the climbing does help with mobility so
i would say that my focus
more than focusing on flexibility which
invokes this image of passive stretching
now laying on the ground with your legs
split and like reaching forward and just
kind of hanging out there for 60 seconds
90 seconds
damn moment van damme fan damn everybody
wants to do the van damn though
everybody wants to do the man damn this
is true
however
where i have had what what people would
consider the greatest flexibility gains
and also just the most practical
transfer
of
seeming more limber it's been through
weighted mobility so acro yoga for
instance involves a lot of pressing
handstand work inversion
a lot of pressing and in the process of
doing something like accurate yoga for
the legs and the hips
or
rock climbing for
less so the upper body but more the hips
the way that you rotate to improve your
reach and so on
has been
really really helpful there's something
called jefferson curls that you can do
and you must do very safely i describe
how to do it
via someone named coach summer
who is the former men's team
men's national team coach how to do
something called jefferson crawl
which is effectively a slow
rounded back
stiff leg deadlift and you're using very
light weights but you kind of you kind
of roll down almost as you would do in a
yoga class vertebra by vertebra
and
when you get more comfortable
underweight in these end ranges of
movement then your body effectively says
oh okay now that we've developed some
strength in this end range we can extend
the end range
interesting so it opens up naturally a
little bit once you've had the
supporting structure there exactly and
it relates to the golgi tendon reflex
and all sorts of things but
when i'm trying to develop flexibility
my question is usually how do i actually
develop
strength at my current limitation
right and that's
also part of the reason why something
called pnf
is very effective for stretching which
is a more active
sort of contract and release based form
of stretching what is what is pnf what
does that stand for proprioceptive
neuromuscular facilitation i believe
it's been a few decades since i've
thought of it
but uh pnf usually i shouldn't say
usually but it's very often involves
partner stretching
where someone would take for instance
your
leg extended you'd be laying on your
back one leg is extended above you they
would push it forward until you reach
the end range of your hamstring you
would then push against them
for say seven seconds and then relax and
then they would increase the stretch and
you would go a bit further and then you
would repeat that is this what you see
like nba players like before they're
about to go into a game you see them
kind of laying on their back and they
have a trainer come in and they're
pushing the leg in there's always a
trainer kind of supporting the leg and
pushing it in they're pushing against it
is that the same type of stretching or
is that different good question i would
suspect it's different just because pnf
can be taxing and you would spread it
out much like you would spread out
weight training gotcha so you wouldn't
as far as i know you wouldn't do pnf
every day for instance you would you do
pnf a few times a week
so my focus right now is
this is going to sound kind of funny
because it's so simplistic but just
feeling good because there are times
when i've been huge right i mean i weigh
170 pounds right now i've been 220
pounds and not fat i mean huge but did i
feel comfortable walking around no i
couldn't turn my head i was like a
turtle you know i had to
rotate at the feet i mean it was
ridiculous
so being comfortable i'm doing a lot of
weighted hiking also so i'd say mobility
meaning strength in the end ranges
strength training and then rucksacking
which i love doing when you have access
to hiking trails which you do in in
oregon certainly and is that with that
one backpack we talked about a long time
ago use this weighted backpack you take
with you it is yeah goruck so goruck is
the brand i use there are many other
brands you can get vests
personally don't love the vests if
you're going to run with these things
which i'm never going to do
then i think the vests probably make
more sense but i prefer to use the
weighted backpacks and i have a 20 pound
a 35 pound a 45 pound and then you can
add different things to that depending
it is a lot harder than people might
think and what you don't want to do is
what i did in san francisco the very
first time i got awaited vest and i was
like well at the time i was really big i
was like i can squat x number of pounds
for y number of reps
no problem i'm just going to put on a 60
pound weight vest and then i i very very
stupidly just started walking with no
plan right i was like well i'll just
walk and then i start getting tired i'll
turn around and
i kept vlogging
and i got to the point where it hurt so
much that i had to take it off and i was
like well how do i get this home i was
like two miles away you know so i had to
leave the weight vest i got a sidewalk
yeah and then
i was like if anybody steals this they
deserve it like they can if somebody's
gonna if somebody's gonna steal a 60
pound weight vest like good for them
because clearly they have more endurance
than i do and so then i had to walk back
sort of do the walk of shame back to my
house without this vest and then get a
car and go pick it up
but
very big on on the rucking very very big
and honestly these days also
this might sound like a cop-out but for
a long time my
maxim was
as far as resistance training goes train
to failure right one one set train to
failure
there are many many many ways to build
strength i'm not saying that it's the
one and only way some people get very
dogmatic about these things
it's just for for bang for the buck like
per minute of workout time that's a
great approach however
as i have
gotten a little bit older and i've been
looking at things like time outside time
in nature sun exposure
i'm not trying to optimize to get it
under 20 minutes or under 30 minutes i
actually enjoy the process of doing it
so those are a few of the ways that i'm
thinking about this if a couple
questions there i'm curious about so
granted this information is a bit dated
but i was i was climbing a lot in my
youth and and did quite a bit of indoor
and outdoor yep and one of the people
that i trained with um it was like a you
know semi-pro climber
that
would tell me a couple things one
every ounce of muscle he considered to
be a potential negative in that it's
some it's weight that can pull you off
the wall because in his mind he's like
it's dense weight and you want to be as
lean as possible and then the second
piece was that
he was a big fan of
low weight high rep
so just you know i mean the guy could do
a hundred pull-ups in a row it was just
like insane right
i'm i'm curious
how's it the pup
yeah it's molly going crazy she doesn't
like the idea of 100 pull-ups apparently
i'm curious what is your style like if
you're not going for mass and you're
going for lean strength
it's not about gaining you're not eating
really high protein then or what are you
what are you doing there
well i did there are also many many many
many different ways to train and i don't
think i have particular insight
when it comes to climbing although i
have asked around i've taken lessons and
have thought about it but
the short answer is i'm doing some high
rep work
like the kettlebell swings are generally
going to be higher repetition
and i'm using a 53 pound and then maybe
a 72 pound kettlebell doing two and
one-handed swings
you get a lot out of that exercise
then
when i'm doing other types of exercises
like inversion training where i'm doing
handstand work where i'm really
developing actually a lot of finger
strength
and
shoulder extension kind of bringing your
shoulders to your ears if your hands
were extended over your head for
instance
as well as
some of the training for bouldering
specifically it's super short duration
so you could view that almost as you
would view power lifting
so i'm not i'm trying to avoid a burn
generally speaking in those types of
scenarios
and i'm looking to build
kind of neurally based
strength better recruitment of motor
units and things like that
uh so i'm combining the two but
certainly
i agree with your friend 100 like the
more weight you got to haul up that wall
the more the harder you're gonna have to
work it's like cycling like cyclists do
not want to have large upper bodies
right
drag that's all it is
and
for me right now
i am perfectly happy to be smaller and
strong
and working on things like climbing
there's no need for me to be large
i think and a lot of people don't want
to be
muscularly large but it's hard to find
anyone who wants to be weak
i think everybody would like to be
strong and you can develop incredible
relative strength
and
really develop yourself as a strength
athlete while adding minimal body mass
even as a male you can do that
i gotta say man the the biggest change
for me going into my 40s that has been
absolutely fantastic well let me
stop for a second
jump back you know i've got a
three-year-old a two-year-old when zelda
started getting a decent size and you
when you have a little toddler running
at you at full speed and they want you
to like catch them and you like you know
especially when it's not straight on
it's kind of out of angle and you're
doing one of these one arm like like
like touchdown like like football
catches with the one hand like you're
doing that with like a you know 25 pound
little dollar or whatever like i
literally like have thrown my back out
like five times like to where i am on
the ground and cannot move and i had to
crawl to my bed and lay there for like a
day and a half
terrible it dude it is like when you i
never knew that back pain because you
know when you're a kid you're jumping
off walls you're doing all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] like you're you know i was
jumping off my house onto the trampoline
like yeah and then you get older and you
realize like things just start breaking
and back pain is a real thing i mean i
know you've had some back issues in the
past like it is no joke yeah and i
needed to fix it so i started doing
um pilates twice a week
and i stuck with it and it's been about
six months now maybe five months and i
haven't had a single issue i have not
had a single issue since developing that
core it is crazy and i can i can toss
the little kids around as much or more
than i could back then it's just insane
to me because like it's a yeah i was
always like you well i would always go
to the gym and be like okay biceps
triceps chest back out right
and like
same you know our shoulders too you know
and like the same workout every single
time and like you look in the mirror and
you're like yeah i look pretty good but
then then it's like you know then your
toddler takes you down yeah tyler
exactly
do you do in person or do you do over
zoom oh man yeah so she's amazing yeah
yeah don't mention her name because then
she'll get the hug of death but i i want
a referral after we finish because i
have been and this is where
a lot of our listeners are probably like
oh my god they've totally lost it but uh
pilates
really technical pilates
is not easy and that's right i have
never felt better than when i am doing a
combination if i if i look back and like
when i have felt the strongest the
fastest the most limber
it's when i was doing a combination of
olympic weightlifting
pilates and acro yoga i felt so limber
and simultaneously strong at all of
these crazy end ranges
and
the pilates with a really technical
trainer is incredibly incredibly
beneficial and there's a lot of
carryover
in the same way the gymnastic strength
training yeah a la coach summer somm er
has a lot of carryover so
despite the
connotations that people might
have associated with that word pilates
and there's a lot of ridiculous
ridiculous stuff also
it's
done technically it is really hard i'll
give you an example remember last summer
i was doing pilates over zoom resume
and a friend of mine was visiting who is
a a former
international level competitor in uh
kickboxing i mean he went to the world
championships multiple times
and
was also a high level athlete in a
number of other sports like he's a he's
a fit guy had
decades of competition
and we got halfway through this pilates
class and he was thinking sort of some
type of kind of side plank bridge doing
stuff with his obliques and he just he
just collapsed and he was like jesus
christ this is embarrassing this is
what's happening
it was great it is not easy no so i'm
definitely a proponent strong proponent
yeah you appreciate all those little
small muscles that you never really pay
attention to and it just like yeah and
it is such a little a good teacher will
get in there and really help you work
all those little tiny stabilizing
muscles
and uh yeah it's it's just fantastic
anyway that if anyone out there is
having back issues highly recommend yeah
check it out and
i think it's easy for people who
lift
weight
in some fashion to be heavily biased
against
body weight or calisthenic type
exercises and it's very easy for people
who do body weight calisthenic-type
exercises including something like rock
climbing
to
sort of glance
a scance at
people who are lifting weights and i
think they are very very complementary
but man
i have seen
some
gigantic bodybuilders and power lifters
do a yoga class and just end up on the
floor because
it is a different exercise yeah so i do
think they they complement each other
very very well
all right i say
with a psy
blockchain
yeah will tim ever make his own nft
i would like your advice here yeah
because
i'm fascinated by nfts i
have tracked them very closely although
i stopped following it quite as closely
maybe a month or two ago
i do find
the
technology very interesting conceptually
i think there are many many many many
many applications of nfts well outside
of say artwork
and i've also made some investments in
opencv for instance which i think
there's a question on twitter also about
picks and shovels and so on i think that
openc
not to
narrowly put it into that category but i
do think that they're in a very good
position to establish themselves as a
dominant player
regardless of what types of standards
might be developed for instance
all of that said
great interest so why the hell have i
not done it i have not done it in part
because there has been this mad
dash and money grab related to nfts and
i don't want to be perceived
nor do i maybe subconsciously even want
to be driven by
trying to capitalize on a hugely
speculative bubble right where the goal
is not to enjoy the artwork the goal is
to resell the artwork for more right so
it's
and that's fine i mean it's fine that a
market exists that's true in a lot of
traditional art as well or i would say
less digital nft type art
so i would love to create an nft just to
learn
more about the process right to mint my
own nft and to go through with all of it
maybe more than one nft
i would be curious to know how you would
think about that if you were in my shoes
or in your own shoes for that matter but
in my shoes because i'm giving you my
confessional here yeah i mean i think
that
with nfts they're you're right it is a
mad dash by a lot of people a lot of
celebrities entering the space and
they are quick to attach their name to a
project oftentimes they're not even the
ones doing the artwork which is also
just kind of like crazy to me like so
you'll have yeah a-list celebrity come
in say i'm releasing an nft and it's
like i did a partnership with this
person and it's like this beautifully
rendered 3d
animated thing and you're like yeah they
actually never touched the computer did
they just like yeah you know it's like
they're just associating their name with
it so which also happens in more
traditional art if anyone hasn't seen
the price of everything i think it might
be the price of anything the price of
everything though i believe or the price
of anything there's a documentary that
goes into some of this but yeah i have
to watch that that's awesome you'll love
it yeah so basically yes there is some
of that also but at the same time though
you have some really legitimate kind of
emerging artists that are using
nfts as this new medium and
i have collector friends that are not
treating it like let's just grab and
flip but they're going to be holding on
to for many many decades so there's a
combination of both that are happening
for someone in your position
you're right there's the risk that you
run is that you launch the tim tim nft
and
it's like oh great tim's making you know
a half million dollars off selling this
nft or whatever it ends up going for he
just did it for the money grab right so
i think if anything man you don't need
the money like just do it for charity i
would donate it all yeah that's i would
donate all but let's take that as an
example okay so 500k what the hell would
i sell for 500k
with the understanding that a lot of
things have sold for i mean there was a
there was you know beepless salt one
piece uh this collage for 69 million
dollars right so there's certainly he's
an incredible artist first i should i
should say like the guy is a machine and
also virtuoso and what he does and also
like insanely funny
you had people on your show yet or no no
no the guy is just a riot he's amazing
yeah and good for him you know because
he
well people can look up his story but i
mean created every day for what 5 000
days straight something like that
clearly not doing it for the money when
he got started yeah i i could not be i
could not be happier that that people
like uh like him are doing well in this
environment
so yes i have some graphic art ability i
could do something that was graphically
inclined you basically have a few
different avenues to explore one i love
the it's putting it underneath the
charity 100 processes go to charity
fantastic boom you check that box no
one's going to complain the second thing
is what do you do do you take existing
media that you have so maybe it's a
portion of one of your episodes maybe
it's uh something that you said one time
that has resonated with a lot of people
that is you know um you want to kind of
memorialize in in an audio clip with a a
cover art of your podcast or you can do
anything you want them to talk talk
episode
yeah exactly i better get some royalties
on that [ __ ] i interviewed you
so yeah definitely split the royalties
with whoever else was on the show
no but the other thing is like you are
an artist like i've seen some of your
stuff you can you can do some amazing
things or you could get super artsy you
can like mash a body part on a piece of
paper and scan it in like you could do
something like that you know you have
hardcore fans i could get all art basel
yeah
tape a banana on a wall
smash a body part against it it's all
for a female there you go oh man
yeah
i mean a lot of people don't know this
probably but i wanted to be a comic book
penciller for probably 10 years so i
spent a lot of time
looking at graphic art was an
illustrator for a period of time so i
suppose i could do that listen i love
gary vee
i love him he's a good friend of ours
you've seen his art out there you know
he's put out some nfts like dude i've
seen your art too i would say that you
have the skills to put out your own nfts
like if gary can do it you can do it
brother like seriously yeah yeah yeah
and i'm grateful to people who are
experimenting and pioneering and
trying all these various things in the
space because not everything is going to
work certain things will work and
you know i feel like also it's really
really hard
to perhaps look at it through this lens
but with nfts like yes there's there are
going to be some amazing things there's
also going to be a lot of noise
but it's kind of like tech companies in
99 or 2000's like yes some someone could
say all of those companies were garbage
but
you know amidst all the noise you had
like the googles and the amazons
that's right and i don't know if it was
in 99 2000 or shortly thereafter but it
was it was in the same window
and
those are
like world changers right those are
history changers in a lot of ways yeah
the thing is it's just a new it's just a
new canvas type you know like i i don't
see it as like
there's a [ __ ] ton of like how many
craft fairs have you been to where you
go down and it's like oh the sunday
craft fair and you're gonna be like oh
my god there's like people are paying on
canvas or like i would never buy that
right yeah yeah so it's just
that's happening in the world of nfts
right anyone with photoshop and the
export and save is ping file can create
an nft you know so totally anyone and
everyone can participate i think that's
a good thing and there will be some
amazing kind of cream that rises to the
top and that is you know we're already
starting to see it there's a handful of
names out there
that are you know nft kind of native
that are starting to gain a lot of
momentum and and and serious collectors
and followings and you know i could like
x copy's a great example of an artist
that puts out these just
crazy almost seizure inducing flashing
nfts no they're insane
but but has been doing it since day one
and now some of his one-of-ones are
selling for over a million dollars and
christie's and they're they're going on
some of the major auction houses and
there's a handful of those folks that
are that are doing some really
unique things in this space so it's not
all crap i guess is what i'm trying i
think art blocks too is another one to
to check out on the generative side
they're kind of like to answer your
question about how do you sift through
all the crap i don't know if you had
that question but i will answer it
[Music]
essentially art blocks they have this
editorial kind of board of other artists
that then kind of vote in who gets
accepted and and put on the platform
and so um the curated side is are the
only the people that meet that bar and i
think we're going to see more of that
there's a lot of that in the curated
marketplace
exactly a lot of that
what is the story with the artwork on
your
your twitter your twitter oh my my
twitter
[Music]
man that june shine's going to my head
uh are you drinking right now are you
really drinking or you just i thought
you were just holding up the kids no no
i just i just scold one yeah yeah no i'm
good it's amazing
uh what is this artwork on your twitter
what you're seeing right there is a
bunch of pills yeah that's that's a
squiggly so
this is this is crazy um essentially
well it's when we're talking about our
block so that
piece of art right there is the very
first project to launch on our blocks
and it is this little
squiggly and it looks very simple like a
little tiny snake a multicolored snake
and
essentially what art blocks is it's a
generative art platform so yeah you
should define what generative is yeah
let's define that so basically
if you think about traditional art it's
always an artist they sit down they do
something they they mint it they painted
on canvas whatever it may be and the
artwork is you know quote unquote done
and then that is then sold
generative art is essentially
a
artist that comes in and says i'm going
to write an algorithm that is a piece of
math that will define the basic
parameters of a piece of art
but
i'm going to introduce some randomness
to it and that randomness is going to be
created by the end user so when you
click to mint a piece of generative art
you are then putting that time code that
kind of timestamp of randomness into the
algorithm and then the algorithm spits
out your unique piece of art so you have
no idea what you're gonna get until it
actually arrives in your wallet and so
what you're seeing there that little
squiggly is something that i minted i
didn't know what it was going to be and
some of them have more rare attributes
than others different colors different
thicknesses
like all these and people collect them
because they love the kind of luck of
the draw and what you're going to get
and they love the output because
sometimes the output is even
more interesting than what the original
artist could have ever you know
contemplated when writing that initial
algorithm so it's just a new i think it
is a
a really interesting new form of art
that can be captured and held by the
blockchain because generative art has
been around for a long time you know
people have been doing computer
generative art and they would always
like you could go to showrooms and they
would have like you know computer
screens or monitors up showing off this
stuff and it was always like a computer
sciencey kind of thing over the last 20
years but there was never a way to
capture that and save it i mean you
could save it as a file but then you
know blockchain actually provided a way
to say okay the output is now captured
and saved in the blockchain it is a
unique asset that can then be
transferred and traded so it's actually
going to give you we can give you a
title right we can give that title to
this unique digital asset exactly so
this is kind of a new form that is only
possible or enabled by the blockchain
which i think is is really fun you know
and so that's why it's getting a lot of
traction i'll give you a sense of how
quickly this market is growing so art
blocks
two months ago did around two million in
secondary sales of all their works of
art this month or sorry not this month
last month because we're just getting
into july now last month they did over
nine million in secondary sales wow um
and so it's just it's really taking off
so i think it's like
third it's like nba top shots crypto
punks and then i think art blocks is the
the third platform they they jump around
say that one more time
uh nba top shots like the nba
collectibles that's number one i mean it
depends on the month because sometimes
crypto punks uh or some other project
will appear that is you know massive and
blows up
but you know crypto punks is the og
original
kind of uh uh not generative art but it
was the the original kind of randomly
created i guess you could consider it
kind of generative in some way but the
random output was was captured with all
these different attributes yeah people
can check it out at larvallabs.com
yeah larval labs is amazing i mean they
they do all sorts of fascinating stuff
really cool stuff and and do you know
that jay-z said his twitter bio to a
crypto punk uh a couple weeks ago
did not know that wow yeah so let me
take a look at that that's a big deal
that's a big deal
huh wow go jay-z
it's one way to add some value to the
market you're participating in
i mean i i feel that it's it's silly for
people to say this is just all hype you
know and there is a lot of that out
there they're like oh this is just gonna
go away it's funny if you look at like
historically when these new mediums come
out like what happens and what people
say i actually did a bit of research on
all this and um i don't know if you knew
this but back in the when canvas was
first introduced uh before that was a
largely like cathedral wall mostly on
wooden planks that
oh are you still there tim
well that was [ __ ] crazy uh my house
got hit by lightning
and the whole
the whole show came to a grinding halt
did your house actually get was it your
house like a hit by lightning or no it's
unclear it's unclear it's unclear but
there was a massive thunderstorm and
lightning and thunder all around this
remote house at an undisclosed location
and
i'm in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere for
context
and everything just went out and i was
like oh yeah this is why you have a
generator this is why i have generators
in places like austin where i was the
only house on my street with power
during the snowpocalypse it's just like
it's it's incredible
we'll come back to jay-z in the crypto
funds in a second but it's just
incredible how fragile the
infrastructure around us actually is
yeah i mean i have the same thing i lost
power for seven days in portland during
this last winter storm we had an ice
storm and it took everything out yeah
it's wild it's wild and you know i do
worry about or think a good amount about
attacks on
the power grid cyber attacks on the
power grid and there's actually a book
that i highly suggest people check out
called lights out subtitle a cyber
attack a nation unprepared surviving the
aftermath by ted koppel
and
it will scare the [ __ ] out of you dude i
feel like these these types of things
just make one more paranoid you know
well you've heard the expression just
because you're paranoid doesn't mean
they're not out to get you right which
isn't intended to be a justification for
like building spider holes in the back
of your
house and
going really above and beyond the call
of duty to ridiculous lengths to prep
in any sense but having some basic
provisions and basic backup plans in
case of disaster i think it's pretty
smart i mean we most
of us have fire extinguishers we hope
never to use them but we recognize that
having one for 100 bucks
or less 20 bucks is is is worth the
downside protection similarly wearing
seat belts like when's the last time you
had a head-on collision not recently
probably but we all wear seat belts
because it's relatively
easy to do that and mitigate high levels
of downside i think generators fall in
that category i think back up water
falls in that category
and uh it's it's just a very present
reminder for me of just how if we saw it
during or personally i saw during
hurricane sandy when i was working on a
chapter related to disaster preparedness
in the four hour chef there's an
extensive section on that which seems to
not match at all with anything related
to cooking
or
chefs but in fact
it does relate it was
kind of too long-winded to explain but
i was
going back and forth with my editor at
the time and they were like look tim
i'm into prepping and even for me this
seems ridiculous
and then what happened hurricane sandy
hit and everything was
totaled and people in new york were
going without power
and
i just think it's a good
so pop quiz
from the universe
in a lightweight way when your power
goes out in this way it's like all right
how much water do you have right how
much ability do you have to charge your
devices without access to the power grid
it's a super basic stuff right so i was
thinking okay we were we were gonna
record this because we were texting back
and forth but as soon as the power went
out what happened all the cell towers
were overwhelmed so my bars went from
like three to one immediately right and
i was like well you suggested we could
record via phone like have the
conversation and just record locally in
quicktime which is what we're going to
do
but that also you have to think out to
like the tertiary effect of something
like that sure and up until a certain
point where you're just like this is
overkill that that's the problem i have
is like where do you where do you draw
the line you know well do you back up
water at home i i mean i have like you
have like a week of water for your
family no
i don't have a week it's like a few
hundred bucks man you should definitely
i mean i've got like well here's the
deal do i need a week of water like
backup like i've got well i'll give you
an example so in austin texas there have
been multiple boil warnings where there
are high levels of rain
some type of flooding the municipal
water
treatment facilities become overwhelmed
and they issue a boil warning so you can
drink the water as long as you boil it
right but i have i have not uh a hepa
not hepat but i have the equivalent of
that on the water side that does 99.99
of viruses and bacteria so i have like
the crazy over-the-top like water
sanitation like coming in to the house
so you can just like take your kids
diapers and recycle it it doesn't matter
yeah you're drinking water yeah i just
pee into the thing it just works
so yeah you know it's i i just view
these things i'm like why not have a few
hundred bucks i get it i have i have
basically i would say probably about
four or five days worth of water yeah
that's good just for you your family can
fend for themselves well just i can get
in a car and drive to some place where
there's water i don't think like
no well that's the thing though is like
in in austin it was like within 24 hours
all water at every grocery store was
gone
right so it just raises interesting
questions for me
uh right because then you're like okay
well if that happens what are people
gonna do they're gonna think about
driving outside the limits of austin
okay
so then what and then what and then
right but i don't think i'm that crazy i
don't think that's crazy no we sort of
i'm not like walking around downtown in
a ghillie suit or something you know
it's like i
do you have a gas mask
i do not have a gas mask i had one in
san francisco and i don't have one do
you have a guest i do not do you have
any type of full body virus protection
suit
like a hazmat suit
i do not i'll see you not that you do
yeah i've got a couple of those
my kids wear them from nine to five yeah
it's pretty standard in the rose
household no i don't have those
in part because right now i'm in a very
rural environment i'm in the middle of
nowhere
but
you realize quickly also without the
amenities of a city center how dependent
you are on things that are easy to take
for granted
like power or telecommunications
and if a tree goes down and lands on the
lines like you're just add a lot till it
gets fixed
yeah i'm on the wait list for those
tesla power walls so i think yeah those
are cool those are cool they're all back
ordered exactly right so that yeah and
then what then the point one percent of
poop in your water is going to kill you
something has to get you man
you're taking all these life extension
drugs and then the poopy water is going
to get you yeah exactly all right so
jay-z you know i looked it up uh while i
was [ __ ] around and messing around
and for those who haven't seen it
mr carter at sc it's actually
surprisingly hard to find on twitter
despite that has three million followers
and zero following
but uh jay-z does in fact have
a kryptopunk as
his profile pick is that the right term
to use that's right that's wild to me
when did that happen a couple weeks back
two three weeks ago wow
it's a big deal it's a big validation
it's a big deal yeah it's a big
validation also i'm sure if he owns one
or 20 of those that
he just
3xed his
investment probably or does that not
translate like what what types of things
affect the pricing dynamics for the
crypto punks and people can look at this
if they go to
larvalabs.com
and then go to projects and click on
crypto punks
you can look at the top sales these
things have been covered everywhere and
like you said they're the they're the
ogs the uh yeah kind of first edition
they're like the model t's
of
nfts so you can look at largest sales so
right now to give people an idea and
when you look at these people are going
to
just end up gaping
jaws falling to the floor looking at
these things and wondering why on earth
an alien with a pipe in his mouth would
be worth 7.57 million that's outdated
dollars
oh yeah there's been an alien sale now
at sotheby's for 13 million
wow
that's crazy yeah i see so i mean these
are 20 by 20 pixel little things too
these are not massive images they're
just so
they just have to be the first you know
they were the first imagine like playing
spy hunter or one of these load run or
one of these really old
games and the graphics associate with
that that's basically what you're
looking at yeah
okay so that's outdated so i see so the
this is and i know these these
transactions have taken place off of the
platform of larva labs
i got it so this is not an accurate
reflection at all of the top sales right
because the top sales are now going off
to sotheby's and christie's and the
traditional auction houses are stepping
in and saying actually we consider nfts
to be real art we're going to offer them
to our collectors which surprise
surprise as you can imagine exactly
surprise surprise
it turns out they also charge a 20 uh
commission on everything yeah very very
very reasonable twenty yeah
suddenly there aren't you know but no
it's cool it's cool that they embrace
this and they put their stamp of
approval they've also done that with a
handful of other projects now some other
really top artists in the nft space so
yeah yeah southwest seems to be really
on top of that i mean they were kind of
ahead of the curve with
the
nfts for sure i mean they're really able
to
capture a lot of that market very
quickly at the high end uh so i have to
give them credit for that
so it looks like now maybe you can
explain to people because i know you i
know you have the explanation but we're
looking at the largest sales at larva
labs dot com slash crypto punks and
you've got two aliens so 7.57 million
and seven point five eight million
respectively then you've got four
gorillas then an alien then a something
i can't even identify i don't think
they're eight why
thank you all right we've got four apes
an alien number eight just looks like uh
i have no like a pediatric cancer
patient uh i don't i don't know what
this i have no idea what that is then a
bunch of aliens not aliens
this is what i get for having too many
hard kombuchas on my random show so i'm
looking for zombies okay you're looking
at the top
yeah all right so what is number eight
what is number eight yeah
uh number eight is so number number six
four eight seven so it just looks like a
plain person right and the reason why
that one is so valuable is it is because
it has zero attributes so there was
nothing applied to it so
if you sort by attributes there's only i
think like seven or eight that actually
have zero or something like that so got
it yeah it's like just like a bald
person
yeah it'll it'll blow people's minds to
look at this in some of the
transactions that are going on so have
all of the highest priced transactions
left
this platform and moved more to the
auction houses and so on yeah that's
right i think the anything anytime
someone has one of these aliens now they
know it's going to fetch double digit
millions of dollars and so they want to
obviously get as many collectors bidding
as possible and what better way to bring
in you know the old money into the game
than to go with the christies or
sotheby's and pull from that collector
base so that's that's been the approach
wild
so wild
that's really
it strikes me as significant maybe i'm
overweighting it
that jay-z has as his profile pick a
crypto punk am am i
overstating that well it's just i mean
that that is really pretty on the nose
right i mean it's not subtle
i think it it also speaks to kind of
what's going on behind the scenes i mean
jay-z
has
a music company called title
which is a big streaming provider on on
on the music side and they recently sold
that to square which jack dorsey is ceo
uh and founder of and also obviously ceo
of twitter they square is now i believe
the number two largest purchaser of
bitcoin because people use square cash
app to buy bitcoin
as you can imagine
there's been a lot of talk around how
artists can potentially monetize you
know songs using nfts or other works of
art using nfts
and you know jack's in the middle of all
that so it would not surprise me that
the square cash app eventually turns
into a way to showcase and kind of
purchase and trade nfts there's been
some
rumors now that twitter is going to jump
into the nft game in some way jack
famously auctioned off his first tweet
from millions of dollars and turned it
into an nft
so you know jay-z's in the mix of all of
this so yeah i'm sure he's he's you know
kind of learning
what's going on and obviously you have
to come back to the original project
which defined the nft standard which is
crypto punks
yeah
so wild what do you what do you foresee
as developments in the
crypto or blockchain space or what are
you watching closely
well i think it's
it's funny because people get so caught
up in these kind of bowl and bear
markets and watching these coins and
saying like oh it's crazy it's down 20
it's up 20
and i think if you
i try not to get caught up in the weeds
there and just zoom out even further
because i think once you do that the
lines start to smooth out a bit and you
understand that
we're in the very early kind of first
innings of this entire rewriting of the
financial stack
and so you know that's part of the
reason why i created the podcast to
cover these things is because there's
just so much going on right now yeah we
need to bring the average consumer up to
speed so they know
how to get into this stuff early before
it's uh you know on paypal.com which is
what bitcoin and ethereum are now you
know at modern underscore phi
oh that's why do you mean twitter yeah
just modern modern dot find modern
finance modern dot finance modern
finance podcast check it out folks
on the tweets on the twitters it's at
modern underscore
phi
all right so you're tracking that you're
saying people get caught up in the micro
cycles that's right and they think it's
over so the fair weather speculators are
going to get their faces ripped off and
panic and then end up in a bad position
it's because they're always buying at
the highs and selling at the lows you
know i mean that's a very common thing
here and and i mean tim you know this
man you bought in right when everything
crashed or just before it crashed
and you got decimated for about 43 years
yeah i did i did yes i did i i
came in in probably what was it mid-2017
something like that
and promptly got my face ripped off
right but you were smart you didn't do
anything you just sat there it's just
like there there isn't a compelling
based on the thesis that i had
i mean which is a fancy way of saying
what i hoped would happen in the future
based on a couple of assumptions
there was no real reason to sell right
it was uh there are these really jagged
acute short-term
moves
but if i actually had high conviction
and the assumptions that led me to buy
in the first place it would be
hypocritical and self-defeating to sell
at that point so i didn't sell yeah yeah
and that was great because that ended up
it's probably what up at least five x or
more since since all that happened it's
up a bit it's up a bit yeah i mean it's
not up as much as it was
i guess end of april beginning may but
that's okay that's okay i mean i think
they're just these sort of hype and
deflation
cycles that you see in everything yeah
right and and and my biggest regrets in
all of investing
are actually the times that i sold
prematurely it's not having invested in
things
it is in
in other words it's not it's not having
missed opportunities to invest it's
having not
uh held the things i invested in for a
longer period of time shopify
sorry shopify shopify was a huge one i
mean that was my biggest misfire of all
time was
but at the time that represented in
absolute dollars a really significant
win for me yeah to try to get to the
point where i didn't have to be
preoccupied
with money so it made sense right look
the logic of selling that actually made
sense
do i regret it yes
a better example would be in
2008
when i had
one
stock that i put a bunch of my like a
very double-digit percentage of my net
worth into can you guess what it was and
i put it in maybe in 2005.
uh wordpress
no
no although i am an advisor to wordpress
and i'm not or rather to automatic and
i'm a big fan
i think of what you would have bought
back then maybe amazon
yeah i bought amazon in like
2005 or something like that
uh
maybe a little bit later
taking a look right now so wait you
regret that no you don't regret that
obviously that's i regret selling oh you
sold it like three years later i sold it
when
the
subprime crisis landed and everything
was just going through the floor
[Music]
and boy oh boy that was a mistake should
have held on to it and i didn't have
clear rules for myself then right it was
i i had rules for buying but not rules
for holding or selling and i think
people at least i get my i've gotten
myself into a lot of trouble
by having rules for buying which i i
sort of intuitively have a pretty good
feeling for i think you have an even
better feeling for it honestly you're
just that's absolutely one of your
mutant powers but then
how long to hold when to sell having
rules for that in advance
is something that i have historically
not been
as good at
and that has been a big problem uh
certainly with amazon is as sort of the
textbook example of that you know
selling 2008 on a panic and now it's
who knows 5 or 10x i have no idea yeah
oops
but yes all right so coming back to
blockchain or crypto i mean there's sort
of like one the ladder is contained
within the former what else are you
paying close attention to so uh of
course you're observing the sort of mass
behavior right and
misbehavior what else are you watching
yeah i mean we do a lot of crypto
investing at trueventures where i'm a
partner
yeah so we've probably
deployed i'd say 50 million or so so far
this year in just in crypto related
deals so
that's a a pretty decent chunk of our
fund
so it's something that we track very
closely and i would say that the problem
for the average consumer is that there's
just a lot of garbage in there there's
just a lot of crap so
you know i would say that unless you're
educated and you are
really deep in the space and you're
listening to all the podcasts and you're
you know reading all the different
coindesk every morning and
if you're at that level then you can
probably go out there and say if you
feel like it you can go out and say i
believe i see where the momentum is
taking things
and so that's kind of what i do as a
profession now i don't recommend that
people do that
you know with their everyday just random
pick of a doggy coin because like all
the
you know there's a lot of there's a lot
of hype around these different you know
meme coins that are appearing
and
those come down crashing as fast as they
go up so we have a problem similar to
nfts where anyone can spin up a new coin
with just a few modifications to some of
the open source software that's out
there make a meme around it pump it and
then dump it and people get burned kev
coin yeah uh tim tim the k yeah we could
do
tim tim tokens
tokens and kev kev going i mean we could
like literally i within an hour we could
launch a new tempum token and and it
would be live and then we could put some
liquidity on unit swap we could get it
trading we get people i mean that
happens every single day yeah so i i
it's really frustrating
and you know it's it's
but it is what it is it's an unregulated
market there's a lot of stuff going on
it's super exciting there's a lot of
innovation happening a lot of really
high quality projects but a lot of of
craft to you know buyer beware so you
just have to be careful on
on how you evaluate these different
opportunities and definitely do not buy
into the memes that are out there like
it's just that those are
those are silly and um
i'm not saying that one of them isn't
going to eventually because there's this
like fine line between community support
and that turns into something real
and a meme right and something that's
being used to kind of pump and dump and
so so would you would you consider
dogecoin a meme coin it started off as a
meme coin and i think that
there are attributes of it that i before
they like em started tweeting about yeah
exactly elon elon started pumping up the
doge well here's the deal with doge like
even the i i knew the founder really
well uh i had him on my podcast
seven years ago or whatever it was
and we talked about dogecoin and it was
a joke to initially it was just like a
fun like he set the supply super high
everybody was using it to tip using
these little bots on reddit and you know
i had literally millions and millions
and millions of dogecoin because they
were worthless
and i was tipping out you know ten
thousand of the time here five thousand
over here like it was just like we all
did it it was just fun right yeah and it
was just kind of like a way like a tip
of the hat to someone like monopoly
money yeah monopoly money monopoly money
so
that has now
evolved into
it had a really strong community back
then it died down for a few years and
then the community came back and then
elon jumped on top of it
but it's still lacking a few things like
the underlying developers that are
working on it now this could be changing
and i've i've heard that they're
seriously considering refactoring the
code base but
it was just a dead project that had
minor bug fixes applied to it so there
was no real outside of it being a quote
unquote meme coin and being hilarious
and watching it go up in price
the
the technology stack that it was written
on wasn't being well
it was being maintained just so that it
didn't break there was no innovation
happening there and so that is not the
future of currency
like the the future like currency that
is going to to
to really be a real true utility has to
have an active development community
behind it supporting it and evolving it
over time and so
that is happening on a handful of other
projects not so much on doge but there
is so much interest in doge now and it
is being listed on a bunch of of the
major exchanges again
i could see it wouldn't be crazy
uh if you said hey kevin guess what five
years from now
they now have you know 5000 active
developers doing all these really funky
weird things on doge i've been like well
that makes sense because it had had the
community drive a lot of that you know
but but they're the the outside of doge
they're they call them like the doggy
coins there are a bunch of other
doggy style coins that are just like
basically
well i'm sorry tim like
they're just they're similar they're
similar doggy coins i'm sorry that your
mind went there
but they're there
they're doggy themed coins that are just
like literally just out there for to get
people excited prices go up the whales
sell and you know
it's it ends in tears and then ends in
tears
so all right so dogecoin that's not a
primary
position in the true ventures portfolio
it is not
yeah okay
uh how do you
well actually a number of questions so
since we invoked the name
of the great elon
you've spent some time with elon i have
really not but
there are those who attribute the recent
correction crash to
various tweets associated with elon
including one
related to the environmental costs of
bitcoin
some think that is overstated some think
that is just something it's understated
a lot of controversy around it
then there are those who would say you
know elon
is
a small perhaps contributing factor but
really it's just a
a overall macro run from risk assets so
even though people attribute
the correction or some people do to
that type of
calms from elon it's it's it's not
really accurate and that it's it's
really a macro trend that happened to
coincide at the same time
what are your thoughts do you have any
thoughts on any of that well elon
certainly carries a lot of weight or
uh i think people more recently even
though he's tweeted a few times about
cryptocurrencies since all this went
down and it didn't seem to really impact
price as much as it did
back when he first started doing it so i
would say he probably has a little bit
less way and people really got pissed
off
when he did this i wouldn't
i think that you know listen we had a
massive run-up over the last you know
six months so
to see a sell-off or correction like
that just totally makes sense to me i
don't know that i'd pay it all on elon i
think that's certainly his comments and
pulling it out of you know tesla from
accepting bitcoin and you know it it
it certainly sparked something that
everyone was already thinking behind the
scenes and that's true you know bitcoin
is a very dirty currency
i would say that i have read reports and
i have talked to folks that are in the
camp of you know they will point out
that the mining operations have really
led to a lot of renewable energy um so a
lot of these bitcoin mines around the
world are placed in places where
renewable energy is there and in place
and operating because it is the cheapest
form of energy now granted there are
other places where it's running purely
off of coal so i don't know that i fully
buy that so you know
i i think that
i'd have to set that aside i don't think
that the underpinnings of bitcoin are
going to be rewritten anytime soon it is
such a you know the fact that satoshi
disappeared it's kind of like this
i know they have folks that are in
charge but it's it's almost like
don't touch it unless it's really broken
there's like just you know it's such a
massive market cap
and it does one thing really well which
is just store of value so
while there is a lot of little
additional add-ons that are helping it
scale no one is thinking about
completely rewriting it from the ground
up in the way that say they're doing on
ethereum like ethereum is being
rewritten right now
to switch to
proof of stake from proof of work so out
of the dirty cpu gpu mining world into
something that is insanely clean and
more efficient and that upgrade will
take place sometime in the next year or
so so there are other
cryptocurrencies that certainly realize
that this is an issue and they want to
get away from
the useless well i mean it's it's a very
you're also
in some sense when you do these
proof-of-work operations that require a
lot of cpu and gpu and are very power
intensive that is how the security of
the network is maintained so they are
useful in that sense but we have i just
think we have better cleaner tech now
that we can apply to the same problem
what are your hopes for
chia if any and could you describe what
chia is
yeah so chia is a cryptocurrency that
was created by bram cohen who's the
inventor of bittorrent we all you know
remember bittorrent from when we were
pirating movies or whatever it may be it
was the kind of first peer-to-peer
elegant way to swap large files
bram went on to create chia
chia is definitely you know it's one of
our investments at true so full
disclosure there yeah me too i'm an
investor yeah the reason why we backed
bram is because i mean
there's
there's a handful of engineers that you
if they raise their hand they say i'm
going to do something new you just
realize that the caliber is just an
animal yeah one of the top tier
engineers in the world so you say always
say yes to something like that so he's
come up with a way to do um a proof of
space and proof of time
uh a blockchain that uses hard drives
for farming so he calls it farming
and it essentially part of the reason
why i was attracted to it initially is
because
everyone has additional hard drive
capacity
and you can turn a normal computer into
a farming rig
that goes out and and will actually plot
and farm and do the same functions of a
cryptocurrency meaning providing
space
as a way to protect the network rather
than just gpu and cpu and it is just so
much more green it doesn't it uses like
one one thousandth of the amount of
energy of say like using a bitcoin uh
cpu or gpu
and
potentially democratizes
in a in a much more broader way and so
what i mean by that is that you know if
you were to compete and you're to mine
bitcoin today you would have to go out
and buy a very custom kind of asics
custom
processor rig or a really fast gpu if
you're mining on ethereum and spend
thousands and thousands of dollars
to go out and participate in the network
so you just can't use an off-the-shelf
computer anymore the way you could when
it first launched you know in its first
uh a year or so
so now with with cheap something like
chia
and you know ethereum's moving this way
as well um with proof of stake you don't
really need the hardware requirements so
you can go out and just use some extra
hard drive space join a pool and then
you can be mining or farming uh kind of
instantly so the number of active
participants in the network goes up
which means it's more decentralized
which means it's better for for overall
security so rather than just be it being
controlled by several thousand you know
the hope is with something like chia you
get hundreds of thousands of people
participating in and doing this farming
and so far it's it's it's been working
quite well i mean they've got a lot of
people they had a you know warning go
went out several big publications wrote
kind of warnings that hard drives were
being sold out everywhere so you
couldn't go to like an electronic store
like best buy was selling out of their
top end hard drives because people were
using them for for mining on chia and so
there was going to be this massive hard
drive shortage so what western digital
stock like went up because of it
and it was just it's just crazy but
that's why it's wild as well but it's um
yeah it's i would say
you know just playing both sides of the
coin obviously i said i was a fan
because we're investors but also you
know it's early days for this so i
wouldn't go out and say hey buy a bunch
of chia
if anything i would say just fire up an
extra hard drive you have sitting around
and play with it and see what you think
like it's you know none of this none of
this is investment advice but yeah
to be clear
here we go we are not registered
investment advisors or other
professionals is for informational
purposes only continue please yes yeah
so i mean with all this stuff though tim
like you know like when i walked you
through some of that metamath stuff one
time it's like the only way to learn
this stuff and to get into it and
understand what you're buying rather
than just blindly buying is to play to
roll up your sleeves and get in there a
hundred dollars in go lose a hundred
dollars or something crazy that you did
doesn't understand but by the end of it
you you do and so that's that's where um
that's where you learn and i think it's
the most valuable piece of all this
so in an ocean of options
and again this is
you and the other partners at true
have significant informational advantage
and many other advantages compared to
anyone almost anyone listening to this
so this is not intended to be advice but
just so
i have a better understanding
how do you vet
how do you choose blockchain crypto
investments because there is
so much out there there's this paradox
of choice
how do you choose things yeah at this
point are there any particular check
boxes or criteria yeah 100 so
the way that i think about it is that
first you have to say
where have we been and where are we
going and so when you start out the kind
of where we've been we've been when
these chains first launched they had one
utility they were like a store of value
and a way to send digital currency to
and from one wallet to another right
that was bitcoin for the first few years
and now when you think about where we're
going
there are just a whole slew of different
arenas that this blockchain technology
has been applied to
so you know you have decentralized
exchanges
you have you know the nfts that we
talked about in marketplaces around that
um all the web three kind of censorship
resistant communication protocols you
have
insanely high performance protocols are
blockchains like solana and some of the
others that are out there and they could
do 50 000 transactions per second and so
what gets unlocked when you have that
type of speed operating on a blockchain
then you have existing big behemoth
blockchains like ethereum and like how
we're gonna scale ethereum in the short
term so you talk about what they're
called layer two scaling solutions the
entire financial stack is being
rewritten from the ground up so thinking
about what is the future of checking and
savings accounts what does it mean to
stream money to people in real time and
how does that work and so you know
there's a world where a startup pitches
not just recently where they figured out
a way to stream money to people in real
time and so what that means is rather
than going into work and like clocking
in and you know waiting two weeks to get
paid
you clock in and money hits your account
every you know 25 to 30 seconds in real
time as it's being earned
and so there's just like this complete
rethinking of of of the distribution
of of financial assets so you know what
once was
if you let me pull up like wells fargo
right now but if you pull up like a big
bank and you say wells fargo wikipedia
and you take a look at the head count
that they have to
uh employ to pull off a traditional
so they have 72 hundred branches in 2021
13 000 atms
and 268
000 employees
for for wells fargo
so think about what that payroll must
look like yeah it's a lot of mouth
should bottom amounts of feed and that
bloat that is in the financial system
and so what do you get in return you
have a checking savings account you get
some fdic insurance which is nice and
you get absolutely nothing you get no
interest
like i get that it's nice that they
handle fraud on the check side and you
know there's there's a phone number to
call and all of that but
all of that money
that is that they're taking your money
and lending it out on your behalf behind
the scenes
and you know their revenue for 2020 was
72.34 billion dollars for 2020.
so
that money now in a decentralized
fashion on the blockchain where
now you have some of these people
writing things like of a some of these
lending platforms or you have like a
block fi that is partially centralized
and partially decentralized
you
have these new banks and new financial
institutions and these new protocols
that are emerging that take just a
handful of people to write code
manage and operate and then all of that
wealth transfer or wealth creation is
being distributed back to the
individuals so i'm excited for the
future of finance because i think that
you know i mean like for example
you know you know i've talked about
block five before yeah you and i've
talked quite a bit about it yes in block
five for example um zach i had the ceo
on my show
we talk about what they're really good
at is is these interest accounts that
give people real
like insane interest at right now i
think it's like 7.5 right now on stable
coins
which is just nuts like what are you
gonna get from bank if you keep a
hundred dollars in your block five
account and then i don't mean this to be
an ad for block file i'm not gonna put
any affiliate code anywhere in anything
in tim's show notes or anything but it's
like it's it's essentially it's just
they're giving you seven percent on your
money on these on these table coins
which are us dollar coins which don't
change you want to worry about them
going up or going down because they're
able to go out and pass that that
savings they don't have that massive
overhead that a traditional bank would
have and they just pass it right back to
the end consumer and so a lot of these
platforms whether it be compound or ave
or some of these platforms you can go
and bring your cryptocurrency in you can
lend it back to the platform and you'll
get paid interest back to your wallet um
which is just awesome it's it's nice to
see that finally going back to the
consumers versus just being kept by the
big banks
yeah it's super fascinating to me and
you introduced me to block fi and
have since become an investor
and
uh don't place a lot of bets in this
space but the idea and who knows net net
like at the end of the day
what the pie chart is going to look like
but the
idea of
a
blockchain first
banking
or finance company is very interesting
and it allows you to do certain things
like offer this 7 or 7.25 or whatever
the the apy is
on accounts that otherwise don't really
exist because as you said there are all
of these intermediate
sort of cost centers including headcount
associated with traditional banking that
are just simply removed right
when you shift to this type of
technology
the ability to say borrow
based on your cryptocurrency
assets or anything that's related these
are some new frontiers in a lot of
respects
and
you know that's part of what makes it
super exciting
so
obviously both of us are fans of block
fight and many other things
what are the risks that you
foresee on the horizon
and i know this is a common question i'm
going to ask it because i think people
will be interested in your answer how
much do you
worry about sort of regulatory overstep
or shut down as we've seen what's
happened in china of course china is not
the united states
but
how concerning for someone who invests a
lot
or for a firm that invests a lot in
crypto and blockchain is
the regulatory side of things honestly
i'm very much looking forward to
regulation i think it's going to be a
great thing the lack of clarity around
how to treat certain types of asset
assets in this world is what's holding
it back i believe you know there's
there's
i i don't think the the big question to
ask here is the one like you hinted at
with china where is it does the us wake
up one day and say actually
cryptocurrency is illegal shut it all
down
and i just can't see that being the case
here
it's too far entrenched in
into everything that we're doing um
every
major bank whether they like it or not
is now embracing blockchain in some
capacity it's a fantastic underlying
technology so
it would just be odd to say we're
banning a certain type of technology
like i just can't see that happening in
the united states
yeah i i hope that there's more clarity
because a lot of it is very confusing
right now and and to be fair a lot of
it's being defined in real time so you
know we
don't know how to handle
certain types of assets like there's
there's just weird things coming out of
this like i'll give you an example
there's a protocol called alchemics
that are these self-repaying loans
it sounds nuts but in the world of defy
what does that mean
it's it's crazy so
basically what i could use some of those
self-repaying loans well basically what
it does is it goes out and you come in
and you take a certain amount of
cryptocurrency let's just say it's ten
thousand dollars right
and they take that entire principle
and they go invest it into yield
generating protocols that are out there
in this world of decentralized finance
and
they instantly give you half of it back
into straight let's just call it a
stable coin like a us dollar stable coin
so you take 10 000 they give you 5 000
to go do whatever you want with and
because of the yield that they're able
to generate on the entire principal
they take all the interest payments and
pay it back into the loan so that the
pays itself off automatically
and you're at the current rates it's a
little over two years and the loan just
automatically
pays itself
back so you're receiving your interest
payments up front if that makes sense
but this is only something that would be
possible in the world of d5 where you're
having smart contract work with smart
contract and not in traditional lending
it just wouldn't make sense because
you're taking all of the benefit and
giving back to the customer and in
traditional lending when you have males
defeated as i mentioned with the wells
fargo example
they would never give you that full
yield back right well they can't do it
right they can exactly so this is like
but what the wheel yeah they're only
making a mere 72 billion right exactly
and the odd thing though is like these
repayments
are happening in
near real time
back to the paying down the loan in near
real time
and so talk about like all these little
micro transactions that are occurring
over that two two years and change now
how do you treat those repayments who's
paying them and where are they coming
from and what's your cost basis and you
can imagine like it just makes you go
across that like no one in the irs is
going to tell you how to do this like
there's this has never been defined
before
so
and
and how do you even file something like
that with the irs to explain to them
what you're doing i mean even handling
basic crypto stuff right now with
with filings is very challenging right
you can do it but it's it's very
involved so there's some very
sophisticated financial
just these these new tools these new um
types of code that is being deployed in
these smart contracts and we don't
really have a clean way to even report
them you know let alone understand how
to uh what tax rate we should be charged
so i i don't know i i'm excited for some
of the more regulation to come into
place i think that but you asked your
question just to remove the uncertainty
so even if the rules are stringent and
punitive in some respect at least the
rules will be
clarity yeah
i want to pay my taxes i don't want to
go to jail i just don't know how quite
to do it right well i wasn't implying no
no i'm just saying i'm just saying in
the world of deep
protest
i'm saying too much in the world of d5
this is what people are running into is
they don't know how to handle this stuff
so
it's a very exciting space but it's a
very kind of bleeding edge you know um
you know enter your own risk kind of
world i to answer your question of like
what am i scared of what are the risks
that are out there i think uh there's a
few
one is you mentioned the regulation side
that that's certainly one that kind of
is off their lingering in the background
which i'm not so much worried about the
the what's going to happen on the us but
i'm worried about what if another
country bans it
because that causes some instability in
the markets when other countries ban it
which would be the most impactful
countries were they to ban crypto
outside of china are there any countries
that stand out that one might not expect
so outside of the us like who are the
players who would really move the
markets yeah that's a good question i i
think china was the big one to be honest
and now that that's kind of over um
obviously the european union would be
huge anything in the with the uk would
be huge but i i i just don't see those
markets cracking down
um so
there's nothing out there that is like
the big scary whale that we're just
waiting for that to happen like i don't
know of any other big countries if
anything we're seeing you know countries
now embracing cryptocurrency and making
it an accepted you know form of tender
like it's it's so that's happening which
is just fantastic
okay so let's put that regulations apart
aside there's two other pieces that i
always think about one is that the meme
coins the the shitty coins that rise to
the top and people think because it's
the top 25 traded coin they should buy
it that's a huge risk the second thing
is that people don't dollar cost average
their way into the markets so that means
that they just buy a big chunk too
oftentimes too much and then they panic
sell yeah so you know dollar cost
averaging is a very simple concept you
have a thousand dollars let's just say
1200 that you want to invest total in a
cryptocurrency you're like listen my
chunk what i can afford for me it's
twelve hundred dollars
you take a hundred dollars and you do
one buy the first of every month for a
year any dollar cost average your way in
that way you're never buying at the high
never buying at the low you're kind of
getting that nice blend over 12 months
12 months may seem like a long time i i
personally would do something like that
over like three to four months and just
figure out what is that don't look at
the markets in terms of like trying to
time it you just say every this is the
day second week of every month and every
monday or whatever it may be whatever
your day is and then you go off and you
make that buy and so that's and the
third piece is like
is that people run into and this is
something that comes up a lot is that
people bite off more
than they take on too much risk so it
has to be something where if it goes it
drops by 75
you will not sell so it can't be so
meaningful
that you're freaking out and you do a
panic sale because this is gonna be this
is where the risk is but also you know
with risk comes the reward obviously so
when you're playing in these crazy
waters these shark infested waters like
there's going to be
some really bloody days and if that's
the case you have to just be able to sit
there and take it and not panic sell
because you know and you believe in your
heart of hearts that the future is
digital currencies and if that's the
case the market is going to be bigger
five years from now 10 years from now
and 20 years from now and that remains
true back to that like what is my
original thesis around this market then
you're going to be good in the long term
but you have to be able to sit there and
close your eyes on those really horrific
days and they will come they'll be
multiple
lots and lots and lots for me i've
realized
if i
am not comfortable
making an investment for at least three
years i just shouldn't do it right
because i probably haven't done
sufficient homework to have
strong conviction
on my base assumptions that should
underlie that type of decision
and if i'm not willing to hold for at
least three years like you're going to
get
punched in the face at least a few times
yes over
three years and
if i've committed to that then
and i've only allocated so much that i
can afford to easily have sidelined
right for that period of time and a
liquid
you're going to end up panic selling
right and just as i did with amazon 2008
which was a huge mistake right i taken
too much
i put it into an excellent company but i
didn't have rules for
when i would sell or why i would sell
right i only had my reasons for buying
but my reasons for buying were based on
kind of present tense evaluation not
looking at long-term trends so i didn't
have
myself set up for success for that
investment which was a bummer and i
ended up selling and then buying back in
in early april of
i guess last year yeah early april 2020
but
uh man oh man it would have been a lot
better to actually hold on to it for the
entire period of time here's the crazy
thing tim i'm curious how you think
about it these days but the one thing
that is a little bit different than what
you said there around stocks versus
crypto is that the people that are the
true believers will say if you really
believe that the future of currency is
digital then there is nothing to sell
like why would you what would you say
what would you sell into because you're
already holding the best form of that
thing that you're holding currency the
the you don't sell into the us dollar
why when they're just printing more us
dollars that would just be silly
totally totally
right so i i don't want to come out with
like super strong opinions but i haven't
i mean i'm generally not selling
the primaries right like the primaries
being bitcoin ethereum like i i have not
sold any bitcoin or ethereum in years
and i don't have any plan to in the in
the near future there are other things
i'm not uh we i don't think we should
name them but more speculative things
that might
on paper
offer a
market cap that just does not make sense
compared to the utility and ubiquity of
other things in which case okay maybe
you take some of that off of the table
but
because there's just not a high there's
not a equally high degree of confidence
in
the durability over time of those things
yeah right
or you just can't find a compelling
logic to be like why why is this worth x
percent of the total market cap of
bitcoin yeah when
uh you know then then i consider that
but i hear you i mean they're definitely
in the true believer camp it's like look
if you actually believe a b and c what
you're saying you should never sell
right the only point where i would never
but never is a strong word though right
i would say
given current information right given
what we know currently given
the current of information i don't have
any plans to sell btc or ethereum right
so in my mind what i think is okay if i
i kind of like you know thinking about
amazon of course amazon's gonna continue
to scale and be the the leader in that
space if i believe the same the digital
cryptocurrency space but i'm in a coin
where
i think to myself
gosh i really see this emerging player
that's coming up that i really believe
in as well
then i might do a lateral move where i
say okay well i have a lot of gains in
this one particular cryptocurrency but i
also want to get a little exposure to
this other one
i'm gonna sell
part of this and then move into another
coin and and that just kind of
diversifies my cryptocurrency basket a
little bit more now one other piece is
we talked about kind of right-sizing the
position that you're holding so that you
don't freak out if there's a big dip at
some point because this i i believe this
market will expand and continue to grow
over the next couple decades
that position let's just say you put in
10 000 you know over the next three
months and that turns into a half a
million dollars at some point you're
gonna look at that whole thing and be
like well this is now meaningful i am
going to freak if it drops by 75
yeah and so what do you do then so my
playbook is one and i'm just speaking
for myself but what it is is if
cryptocurrency grows to the point where
it is no longer you know whatever your
number is 10 of your overall holdings 20
whatever you're comfortable with and all
of a sudden it's 40 of your overall net
worth
then
my way of trimming is not to say sell
and grab some us dollars what i do is i
say let's sell
but then diversify into
stocks and bonds and more traditional
assets so
more of the wealthfront style kind of
fully diversified you know
that to me is more the boring
old school hoping for seven percent a
year
you know type of sell investing but i i
i'm i'm i'm definitely not one of these
people you talk to pomp or something and
you'll be like oh i'm 100 bitcoin you're
like what socks do you hold no no just
just bitcoin you're like wait what like
like uh that that's a little aggressive
you know so i i'm definitely a fan of of
having you know other assets as well so
it's not just all about crypto
yeah totally
and i should say also i mean seven
percent sounds terrible but like if
if it's a decent number to begin with
and you don't
sell and rebuy and
rack up all of these transaction fees
and management fees and so on
uh you could do worse yeah
oh totally
like people a lot of people go to zero
trying to chase like 40 annual returns
uh and i'm actually i have a lot of
sympathy for people who had the
experience their first experience
investing
in this last run-up with crypto because
they're just ruined forever yeah you
know in a way i'm just like oh my god
like
this is i don't want to say a
non-recurring phenomenon but it's just
like if if your
baseline is set at
hundreds of percentage per year
it will be very hard to convince you
that it makes sense to invest in
something with a reasonably predictable
seven to ten percent per year let's just
say
and that's a tough position
psychologically yeah for people to be in
you know absolutely the one hack i did
want to share with the audience that i
think is a really worthwhile one
is
well i don't wanna i also i'll say it
like
i think that the mistake a lot of
cryptocurrency holders are doing today
is that
they are holding their cryptocurrency
where they're not earning anything for
their cryptocurrency so a lot of people
will have a robin hood account i'm an
investor rob hood so i'm like i'm
slamming them right now and i'm sorry
i'm not an investor we invested at
google ventures and i hold some of their
funds so i'm i i don't mean to talk bad
about robinhood but they don't give you
any interest when you're holding your
crypto there the same thing goes for
coinbase coinbase just now said if you
have our stablecoin usdc will give you
four percent but
actually they do ethereum two staking
which is nice but outside of that
they're not really giving you any
interest if you hold bitcoin there
there are some places that you can go
that you can transfer your
cryptocurrency to
um you know paypal doesn't give you an
interest that you can earn interest on
your crypto paid in crypto so you paid
in in kind so you're getting more crypto
as you're sitting there holding it so
my strategy is that
there's two sites that i like block fi
and then all which we already mentioned
they give you interest on ethereum
bitcoin a whole slew of other coins and
then gemiini is another really
world-class exchange that gives you
interest on just holding your crypto
there so every time i launch my wallet i
see that i have more crypto because
every month i'm earning interest on it
and i just would hate for people
to be letting their crypto sit there and
not earn any type of of interest now
there are risks because they're they're
lending your crypto out on your behalf
but you know the
that's why actually i to plug my show
again i did an episode all around with
risk with the head of risk of both of
those
organizations to talk about how they're
doing it behind the scenes and after
listening to that episode i'm i'm
confident and comfortable in what
they're doing so yeah i've been doing
i've been using blackfy for years now
and getting
outrageous interest rates um which is
you know it's a great thing to do when
you're sitting on some crypto why not
earn more
here here
what else should we talk about
yeah so we covered crypto pretty well
[Music]
thank you for the wii
yeah i'll take it it's a fun world man
you're doing fine tim just keep holding
here
there you go thank you i'm just
breathing while i listen yes thank you
i'm doing great this is great
you know one thing i wanted to cover is
a question came in from twitter saying
asking and i guess then we can wrap it
up unless you have more but one of the
ones that we have on the last on our
list here is um
the most recent thing you've added to
your daily architecture any new rituals
question mark
and i was going to i was really curious
when that came in because i i we haven't
talked about this in a while like what
have you picked up
both in covet and then kind of like a
coming out of slowly coming out of kovid
anything
new for you
so the first thing that comes to mind
uh is
anything in all things related to sleep
this is a perennial topic but
you know in the last i would say month
i've had probably 10 days at least of
the best sleep i've ever had and
a lot of that stemmed from a
conversation i had with a neurobiologist
from stanford named andrew huberman
really interesting guy
and we talked quite a lot about sleep he
studies the visual system
very intensely was he on your podcast
yeah awesome yeah he was on daria's
podcast too recently which is great yeah
he's he's a smart guy he's a smart guy
and we spoke a lot about
sleep we spoke about testosterone and
increasing testosterone we talked about
performance the risks of increasing
testosterone different methods etc and
in the sleep
camp we
or i should say he rather told me about
increasing
fish oil specifically
epa to at least one gram per day and
i've been taking fish oil but i not been
taking that quantity
and i began taking fish oil and
a number of other supplements
including magnesium beyond just
magnesium three and eight which is very
good for sleep
and on top of that paying more attention
to
circadian
and cyclical cues that he and i talked
about so
i've been trying to ensure as soon as i
wake up that i go outside and spend
at least five minutes in the sun and
i'll do that by jumping rope
and walking around with molly my dog but
to really ensure that
to the extent possible i don't wake up
and then brush my teeth and then check
my phone and then check my calendar and
sit inside
dilly dallying or
even doing important work for an hour to
before getting outside exposure
i've really been trying to
very consistently get
sun even if it's cloudy outside just
like solar sky exposure as soon as i get
up
and
i've been having some of the best sleep
in my life it's really really really
remarkable what are you using to track
your sleep
right now uh because i shifted locations
recently i mean not full time but i'm
just i'm i'm outside of of my usual home
base so i have an aura ring that is
charging i haven't been wearing it i do
use eight sleep
on the bed which is incredibly helpful
yeah creating two zones and
you know my girlfriend if she could
sleep inside a sauna at 90 plus degrees
she would probably do it i i really need
to sleep at
sort of a
surrounding temperature of like 67
degrees or i have an incredibly hard
time getting to sleep
so the eight sleep does provide some
tracking and i found that that eight
sleeps
i suppose inference or extrapolation
from what they can sense in the bed is
pretty good even when they're paying
attention to hrv certainly the number of
times that you're tossing and turning
getting up etc uh surprisingly
accurate from what i can tell i was very
skeptical
i do use the ora ring that's going to be
the primary for looking at sleep quality
and
hrv
so those would be the two tools
predominantly but
you know at the end of the day even
though i find these tools very useful
you know by 1pm if you had a good
night's sleep or not yeah and you
probably know as soon as you get up yeah
and so it's it's a subjective feel as
much as anything else and
i am a different person if i get three
or four nights of excellent sleep i am a
different human being like qualitatively
and probably quantitatively in a bunch
of ways i am just a different human
being
so so those are those are a few of the
things that have changed couple
questions yeah so when you are when you
have a bad night's sleep and you look at
your aura data what does that mean for
you does that mean lack of rem sleep
lack of deep sleep or is there anything
that jumps out
yeah for me it's it's lack of deep sleep
yeah it's lack of it's lack of
restorative sleep and i don't know
how deeply
pun intended i should read into that but
my deep sleep is very easily compromised
uh it is very easily compromised also if
i have more than two alcoholic drinks of
course not all alcoholic drinks are
created equal
so six percent is very different from
like tequila shots
but
i've paid a lot of attention to that
and
that is another reason why i was
actually more than happy to have a drink
or two
this early since we started recording at
3 p.m my time
because if i drink a little bit earlier
this is not this is coming out really
off terribly because i'm not suggesting
that people become day drinkers
but
if i drink at say
happy hour like an early happy hour
which is not really my thing but just
for the sake of illustration like like a
4 or 5 p.m
i'm eight my body is able in a waking
state to
seemingly metabolize a lot of that
before i go to bed
and i consequently do not wake up with
the rapid heartbeat that's the worst man
the alcohol night sweats it's the worst
i hate that rapid heartbeat where you
wake up and you just got that like
feel it going and you're like
you can't oh water you can't do anything
worse yeah you can't you can't do
anything you just have a terrible
night's sleep
so having even an additional three hours
to metabolize before going to bed
makes a huge difference for me so i've
been paying attention to that as well
but almost all of my changes recently
have been associated with improving
sleep quality can i ask you what um type
of
what manufacturer of omega-3s do you
take
yeah i can tell you let me grab it
all right tim has left the room
let's see if this makes the edit or not
i'm betting it's carlson wild caught
omega-3s
okay
here we are
you have another one
these these are delicious
uh
don't judge me kevin this is not my
usual but
in any case all right so the uh
the first i've two here this is a nordic
naturals pro omega 650 epa 450 dha
and that is right here
this guy
uh which i've been using and then the
second that i have is thorn
that's
t-h-o-r-n-e
super epa
that's this guy right here cool uh so
those those are what i ended up choosing
and
the effect is really
remarkable and it's difficult
i would say it's impossible let me be
clear it's impossible for me to say
that my sleep quality improvements are
entirely caused by this
i'm also spending more time outside i'm
doing rucksacking i'm getting more
exercise i'm getting a lot more sun
exposure i'm in nature my body tends to
just
down regularly it's not the right word
but my nervous system
downshifts a lot when i'm surrounded by
nature
so there are many factors
there are many environmental changes in
my life that have taken place in the
last few weeks but i have spent a lot of
time in nature at many other points and
my sleep has not had this dramatic
change so it leads me to think that
there are other causal factors and this
is this is the most obvious this is the
most obvious thing yeah that's awesome
yeah i've been taking a couple grams of
omega-3s for for a while now um and i
just find for me i i actually see the
benefits on the joint side like i just
have less like totally joint issues
yeah i've noticed i've noticed that
actually in my feet i have uh it's like
the old man episode i love that this is
the old man episode but my family has a
history
of gout so my family has
gout on at least the maternal side and
a sort of precursor indicator of that is
often high uric acid levels and i've
been pretty loath to start
another medication which will be a
maintenance medication forever in this
case would be allopurinol dude i've been
taking out pnl for five years now yeah
even though it's very very well
tolerated right as far as drugs going
it's very well tolerated i'm like oh god
i'm gonna end up
that old guy with the pill case with a
hundred pills that i have to take every
day too late dude
i don't take that many things right now
i've really tried to minimize it
although compared to the normal people i
probably seem like a complete disaster
in any case
the epa
or perhaps it's both including the dha
the higher levels of
fish oil consumption
unexpectedly i was stretching and i
noticed oh wow i don't have that usual
stiffness which i thought might be some
type of degeneration in the joint
although i had x-rays and it didn't
appear to be the case
the stiffness and pain that i feel on
that big toe joint which is very often
where gout first presents
which i was very concerned about
[ __ ] i've gout really am i like some
fat aristocrat from like the 1700s in
france like what is this like really how
can i have gout
and
uh some people think that that's
primarily
caused by i think it's purines in dna
and that's associated with with protein
and therefore people take by extension
that to mean that animal protein should
be decreased
it's not quite as simple as that uh
there's actually a chapter that i
i published on my blog to blog people
can find it
on gout and
the understated culprit which is
fructose
as found in high
fructose corn syrup and in fruit to a
lesser degree
so it's not quite as simple as people
might paint it to be nonetheless what i
noticed is like holy [ __ ] like that pain
in my toes is like 90 gone
after a week of doing it and i i cannot
think because this has been consistent
for years now that i've had this oh
interesting this pain i mean it's been a
it's been a kind of a
static
level of pain and after a week or two
again maybe it's placebo who knows but i
wasn't anticipating this as an effect so
it's hard for me to think that it's
expectation
it's like you know what it's hard for me
to come up with many reasons not to do
this so
i'm going to give it a go if you take
too much more is not better and i think
you could probably cause intestinal
bleeding or all sorts of problems if you
were just
to chew these like
gummy bears or something so uh you know
word to the wise uh talk to your doctor
about things like this but i've
certainly found it beneficial what about
you your daily architecture
yeah i mean i would say that's a very
kind of highfalutin way to put it but
yeah your your daily architecture yeah
the only thing i would say that i've
i've really stuck with that well a lot
of people want to know about our sauna
routines and if we're still doing sauna
that was a hot topic in the in the
hot topic doggy style i gotta tell you
man this sauna
sauna for me has been it's just the best
it was it's the best money i've ever
spent outside of having a nanny from
time to time
uh
it's it's like sauna
sauna is just so
key i just feel so much better i mean
there's all the health benefits and the
studies they just get there's more and
more coming out all the time i will say
one thing one a pro tip do not oil your
sauna
so i oiled my sauna
what does that even mean like so they
have this sauna oil on amazon
and it's like when the wood dries out
you're supposed to put oil on it you
know okay so i buy the sauna oil on
amazon
i oil it and then it literally
off-gasses like smoke like smoky oil oh
that's terrible for this dude it's been
doing it's like a skillet on the
stovetop that's terrible and so
i was like okay
this is crazy so i went in
i sanded it down
like tried to get it all out you know
scrubbed it with like soap and [ __ ] and
then dude it's still off gassing so then
i started wearing my n95 mask in there
and so doria is like that's why you need
a gas mask to use your own skin yeah
it's like what are you doing she's like
i'm not going in that sauna again and
i'm like listen i'm like let me burn it
out because it but i still need to get
my sauna on so i i use my gas mask and
then
dude i go in there and my eyes when i
walk out after after 20 minutes my eyes
are bloodshot because the like the smoke
is hitting my eyes and my eyes were
burning it's not the gummies no it's not
the gummies it's not your gummies that
you hand make and send me my gum um
the honestly it's just like so i i
ripped out my entire sauna had all the
wood removed and had to buy a new sauna
oh what a mess yeah so that's wow anyway
so routine wise architecture wise it's
been one year almost coming up on one
year of meditation and that my friend is
the biggest game changer i've ever had
is when i decided to take it seriously
and not just
do it like an app just but like really
sit and and do it really like real
practice
so what does real mean this is an hour a
day you know what's funny tim i never
told you and it's zen zen style this is
this is with your teacher it's zen style
yeah in accordance with his instructions
that's right so what's funny tim is one
time i don't know if you ever remember
you we were talking about meditation
this was probably
seven six seven years ago
and you said
something to the effect of like i i i
think that most people will they just
close their eyes and think about things
when they're meditating or like you
didn't like it's almost like you didn't
believe it
oh i still think that's true
i mean i think there are benefits to
meditating but i think most people are
just thinking about [ __ ] with their
eyes closed
yeah yeah
i was gonna ask you have you ever
found
yourself in deep on have you ever
meditated to where you've been like i
mean because you did the you did the off
site you did the you're really famous
you talked about that yeah the pasta
like uh
psychotic
breakdown
yeah that was pretty deep having a full
psychotic break i would say it's pretty
deep i i have felt
yes i've had very very deep experiences
some of the best experiences i had
were actually
i'm blanking on the style and the name
currently
give me some hints
naval would have the answer i'll tell
you the
the general approach and the general
approach
is
having
nothing to do you actually sit there you
do not repeat a mantra you do not pay
attention to the breath you just sit
there and
this is going to sound paradoxical but
you actively try to do nothing you just
sit there
and doing this in a group environment
for a period of time
did it with a small group
and
this was one hour in the morning one
hour
let's just call it 5 p.m like 8 a.m and
5 p.m
and doing it in a group i do think there
is a dynamic that has gained
certainly a different dynamic that
presents itself in a group i don't have
any explanation for this
either there are theories certainly pet
theories but
doing it in a group two hours a day for
a period of even a week produced some
very very very very deep states
and i would say
in terms of kind of roi in a short
period of time i found that very
interesting when i came back to
so-called normal life i did not sustain
that twice daily cadence for very long
and i think in part because i was doing
it by myself
with my girlfriend and not in a group
having that accountability was very very
helpful
but i have experienced some very deep
states in meditation have you found
those to be pleasant states or just kind
of um
like when you walked away did you have a
smile on your face did you feel like you
felt oh very pleasant very very peaceful
yeah very pleasant and very at peace for
sure
oftentimes
what i've noticed this can be
for me at least
facilitated by
doing a very intense but short sauna
session for say 15 to 20 minutes
and then sitting outside and sort of air
cooling and meditating for 20 minutes
yeah that's nice that's just a great
feeling oh it's incredible found that to
be very consistent so to answer
someone's question that you brought up i
still do sauna very very regularly and
view it as a key
and simple lever that i'm able to pull
for
mental health whether it helps me
physically or not i don't know i mean
maybe sure heat shock proteins all of
that yeah okay maybe i'm not gonna know
if it did anything until i'm dead so
uh jury's out but
from just a day-to-day
psycho-emotional
and mental perspective
doing a sauna
especially late afternoon if i do it too
close to bedtime it interferes with my
sleep but if i do it you know four or
five o'clock
then it seems to help
and also dramatically increase hiv the
next day oh interesting yeah yeah i've
noticed that as have a couple of other
people
but coming back to architecture in your
meditation so one year anniversary
congratulations
that is the anniversary of what maybe
you can describe for us yeah so i mean i
had been like most people that have ever
played around with meditation apps you
know i've been dabbling uh and even you
know helped build one that is a free
meditation app but
i i just was dabbling i was always
dabbling i was doing the 10-15 minutes
maybe 20 minutes you know just those
little sessions guided and they were
fantastic very
very great prescriptive meditation oh
you have something wrong you're feeling
stressed you know if you're flying
whatever it is like there there's all
these courses for that you can take them
you know there's not a lack of apps that
offer this type of content
i think that the shift and the change
was telling myself that this is a long
road
to practice to really train the brain
like if you think about
what we if we want to do anything at it
and tim you know this way better than i
do if you want to do anything you know
if you want to be really good at
something
it can't just be an afterthought casual
i'm going to make time for this when i
feel like it exactly so i made that
shift in my brain and said okay
i believe there is
something worth pursuing here
that a dedicated
longer practice longer duration
in a more serious discipline so for me
that was a form of zen called sanbozen
[ __ ] yeah sanbo's like the the uh
offshoot it's more kind of a lay zen how
do you spell it s-a-n-b-o
sambo's yeah so when i heard about this
and and was introduced to to my teacher
henry you know got excited about it and
really decided to dive in and say okay
i'm going to read a few of the books
that are out there on this type of zen
and then
create a real practice that is you know
55 minutes of sitting a day how much is
it 55 minutes
why 55 minutes well you do 25 i like
fives but yeah you do 25 minutes of uh
your first sit and then you do a five
minute walking meditation and then
another 25 minute set
okay cool yeah and for those wondering
so as i just looked it up
is a lei zen sec derived from both the
soto and the rinzai traditions [ __ ]
literally means three treasures i wonder
where the treasures are
sang is like each nisang sang three
[ __ ]
like my
my darling my treasure kind of thing uh
but yeah [ __ ] is three treasures and
then cure
well we can get into the japanese
another time but yeah kyodan religious
organization or teaching organization
that's cool
so 55 minutes what do you know what the
three treasures are yeah the one
treasure is the sangha so the the group
the other one is the dharma uh the
teachings and
the third one is escape me right now you
can just type in three treasures it'll
there three treasures apply more to than
just [ __ ]
okay yeah here we go okay wait a minute
three jewels are the buddha the fully
enlightened one the dharma the teachings
expounded by the buddha hence the term
or phrase dharma talks if you've ever
heard that and the sangha the monastic
order of buddhism that practice dharmas
but that's also
colloquially thought of as the group
that practices together
roger that okay so you've done 55
minutes a day for a year
i will say that i have certainly missed
a few days but nothing nothing crazy not
like where i'm like oh i missed that
entire week like there'll be a day or
two where it just didn't work out
and there's been also a handful of days
that are on the 25-minute side like
there was definitely
uh versus doing the 55 but yeah for the
most part i've been really consistent
what is the practice what is the session
i know you mentioned it in brief already
but what does a session
look like and feel like to you
well i it depends on where you are in
your practice when you're first being
instructed the
teaching is essentially kind of counting
or just following the breath so very
almost like vipassana style yeah just to
get that base level of concentration
honed so you know it's a very like
there's a teaching where they talk about
the zen master that was sitting and and
the concentration it was so intense that
they're they're sweating like you can
see sweat on their brow because they it
is like a very
active thing that is happening with the
with the the honed concentration
yeah they hit you with a switch if
you're nodding off they still do that if
you would like to request it you can go
in the in the zendo and you can request
that that happen it's not for pain it's
for a jolt you know like i mean it's not
like a beating practice you know
this is for you not exactly
so um yeah so that's that the initially
it's just that initial kind of counting
and awareness and then
eventually if your teacher and you feel
you're ready for it um you know you take
on a koan which is one of these
things to sit with like uh just a zen
kind of
saying or word to sit with
that is used as kind of a
what's the best way to put it kind of
like just a
helping aid it's like a paradoxical
cue right right or it's uh something
like that yeah paradoxical anecdote or
riddle used in zen buddhism demonstrate
the inadequacy of logical reasoning and
to provoke enlightenment
that is the definition that comes up for
me yes
so what you do is when you sit with that
con eventually you will be able to
answer it and there are hundreds of them
and there are checking questions that
are done with your instructor checking
questions that's right so if you sit
down with a zen master
and they ask you
uh you know probably the most famous one
is
the sound of one hand clapping yeah
right
you would then be able to answer
that question through a series of checks
and
eventually you can go through and kind
of answer all of them so you'd be able
to answer all of them so there's a right
and a wrong answer
yes to something like more or less wow
oh god damn that's stressful
but i mean they get you you get it wrong
a lot so essentially like if you're
going to do one of these they call them
like a session where you go and do these
like multi-day retreats
you will go and you will sit and then
you have a
one-on-one
session with your your zen master at
that in the evening when you're kind of
wrapping up you know and they'll sit you
down and say
you know what is the answer to this
question whatever you're sitting with so
some people sit with the most common one
is one called mu
and they'll say you know what is mu and
if you and then you could either say i
don't know and you can walk out and
that's fine they ring the bell and the
next person goes in or you can try and
answer it
and wait what is moo i mean not that i'm
not asking you to give the cheat sheet
for people but
i don't know the answer to that question
but broadly speaking is moo
a character yeah so it's a does a
japanese character foreign
so basically where that came from is
there was a very famous zen teacher zen
master named joshu and joshu
um was asked by a monk one day the monk
asked joshu does a dog have buddha
nature
and joshua's answer was just mu
and that was coming from
they will tell you that answer was
coming from a non-dual world so it was
like
it's kind of hard to explain and it gets
gets a little tricky yeah exactly so
what you do to give you a i can give you
a breather if you like yeah i've got
some i've got some stuff but yeah
so you just basically sit with um
i'm just saying if you want a moment to
gather yourself because there's some
pretty esoteric [ __ ] i can i can i can
read what i found on the subject the
checking questions you can read the
answers
no no
what you found
read the answers like these
practices like like the mantras for uh
for transcendental meditation where
they're just listed out by age that's
right yeah i could do that and just like
to really make everyone cry the uh and i
say that as someone who paid for the
training and still uses tm
i still use it so teachers may probe
students about their koan practice using
such checking questions to validate
their satori understanding although i
would debate the translation of satori
there or kenzo which is a really cool
word like seeing the nature uh seeing
the phenomenon for the mukon and the
clapping hand khan there are 20 to 100
checking questions depending on the
teaching lineage the checking questions
serve deep in the inside of the student
but also to test his or her
understanding
that's wild that there would be
questions i'm just trying to imagine i'm
not asking you to spill the beans on the
secret cult that you've joined but
the questions that would be related to
something like what is the hand
of one hand class yeah but the thing is
it seems like it's unanswerable by
definition because it's intended to show
the
inadequacy of logic that's right and so
the best way it's been described to me
and this wasn't by my zen teacher but
i've heard it described elsewhere is
like the answers are going to be
something that you will only understand
if you've had that kensho awakening type
moment or you would only be able to
provide
so your answers in the same way that
when the monk asked you know does a dog
have buddha nature and joshua's response
was moo like that would make no sense
make no sense at all
so your answers are also going to make
no sense in this
plane if that makes sense but your
teacher will understand them because
they will be
listening from another plane so that
makes sense
kinda sorta i mean it's it's
it was oh here let me give an analogy
it's gonna be terrible
you're gonna love it
uh so it's like if you're trying to
explain
like ejaculation to someone who's never
ejaculated and you're like it's kind of
like a sneeze in your balls and they're
like what and like there's never going
to be this is a bad one
if they've had the experience of exactly
and then like there's kind of no
explanation needed and you can give like
a moo type answer like oh yeah yeah i
hear you moo it's so moo that stuff is
so moo i don't know that that's how i
describe it but that i like it i mean
you're you're welcome yeah that's you're
you're practically a zen master tim this
is the three hard conventions later i
think i'm enlightened i think it's great
no but i i that's that's the gist of it
is like we would never even if we read
the answers they would it can't be a
reading based logic based answer it has
to be something that you have a felt
experience of
through this thing that is given and
that's why there's so many checking
questions
because they'll they'll be checking from
a bunch of different angles whether or
not you've actually felt or had the
experience versus
being like just like a red response
yeah that's super interesting i think
the yeah honestly i mean even though in
some respects they're very different
there are similarities meaning in the
psychedelic
in the psychedelic
ecosystem in in the realm of whether
it's psychotherapy assisted by different
psychedelic compounds or
otherwise either there could be a place
for these type of checking questions
interesting uh and actually in some of
the indigenous traditions there are
i don't want to call them fact checking
questions but there are sort of
standards and
experiences that are thought to be
representative of different levels of
awareness
within the context of say an ayahuasca
experience
so they're not that dissimilar they're
actually very similar and i should
correct something i said earlier because
i was thinking of a different character
kinshol the show is different than the
there are a lot of
homonyms in japanese a lot of things
that have the same pronunciation so the
shul in kensho is a different character
than i had envisioned
uh it's it's nature or essence is the
show ken
is to see
like ken gaku if you wanted to go to say
a judo
school and observe but not participate
you would ask if you could do ken goku
kengaku is gakus to study so it'd be
like visual studying
that's super cool man i'm so glad that
you're
digging deep into all this it's great to
see you stick with something for a year
yeah seriously it's gonna be a long
journey man but you know
now's the age to get started
yeah why do you think you've stuck with
this uh i mean you so there's a uh
oh god what is the expression since
we're on oh well we i say just like we
explained to cryptocurrency and
blockchain stuff earlier which was
basically you talking
uh i'm kind of on this
you know speaking in tongues japanese
kick right now but
there's this expression i think it's
i think that's what it is somebody who's
a native speaker of japanese could
correct me but there's a
there's an expression in japanese which
is like
he he or she gets hot quickly and gets
cold quickly meaning they pick up
habits and routines and various things
and then they stick with them for very
short periods of time like they get
really excited about something and then
they just drop it
right which i think you and i both do
although i think you take it to a whole
new level
so why do you think you've stuck with
this
for a year in the way that you have what
what has changed in you or what is it
about this particular thing
that has has grabbed you
well i would say that
i
i told myself that
i knew
that the upfront work of just being able
to sit for an hour and be comfortable
with it
was going to take some time
and
to spill distill the mind to the point
where
you can just get comfortable and not
feel like just this crazy effort that
you're like why the hell am i doing this
is is a lot of work but i said i'm gonna
push through
until i can at least get to the point
where
when i get up off the cushion
i feel
better than when i sat down and i don't
feel like it was a
just a waste of my time like oftentimes
and and that's a it's it was a challenge
initially to say can i calm my mind
to the point where i will actually
consider this a net positive
and i say it took about three months
took about three months to get to the
point where when i would get up after 55
minutes i would say to myself
this is great i feel really good
how did you stick with it for that long
three months is not i mean it's not the
you know we're not talking about like a
hundred years of solitude but it's it's
it's a non-trivial period of time for
someone who operates at really high rpm
so like why
even have that as a goal honestly tim if
i'm being really truthful it was because
i was
really depressed
we had a lot of stuff going on both in
the country and with a pandemic and
having a second child and just having
all this stress hit all at the same time
i just felt like
i just needed something i just needed
something to be able to sink into that
wasn't the news that wasn't what was
going on around us yeah and it was right
during the pandemic that i decided
that's why i decided to do this was
because i just couldn't
i just i
you know you're sitting at home and
you're not really going out and doing
anything and it's just like i can either
drink
you know
or or insert any other bad thing to do
here or i can pick up something hey now
hey now
i hear you no but like you know it's so
that was it was it was a lot of that
where i was just like i thought we were
all gonna die and i was just like yeah
for sure i need to go deep here and then
luckily that was enough of a driver to
get to the point where then it was
tolerable and then enjoyable
i'm so happy for that
yeah it's dude it's it's i'm dude i'm
not anywhere close to being anything in
this world in the world of zen like it's
gonna be
20 plus years or longer for me to get
really really deep but
i'm two things i'm glad i started
because i am at the point now where it
is enjoyable
and two i would say that the only thing
i've noticed is that i don't
little things that just used to get
underneath my skin
really don't quite hit me as hard and so
those little
little edges have been sanded down a
little bit those little rough edges
and so
i can take a sharp elbow with these in
ways that i couldn't before so
i think that's that's the one benefit
and and whatever else comes on top of
that is gravy and i'm excited for but
you know
it's also super weird
zen buddhism and
i think that that is a more
accurate reflection
of what we call reality than
the kind of clean abstracted
pictures we like to paint
of reality that we would that we would
like to be the case because it allows us
to grasp it and kind of
navigate it so
much more easily
you know for that reason
i think that the journey through zen
buddhism actually has a lot in common
with deep study of psychedelics i think
they're very similar because the further
you get in the more you realize nobody
[ __ ] knows what's going on like this
is actually very very like the the more
i know the less i know
in a sense and
i find that very liberating actually
yeah and i yeah i find it very
liberating it's like nobody knows what's
going on okay all right well as long as
my goal is to eventually get you to
study some zen i think you would be so
you're the perfect person for it because
it is there are actual
obtainable things you know what i mean
like yeah like
in some sense the whole practice is not
about it it's about obtaining nothing so
it's not like it's like
but but the fact that there just are
checking questions is like
it's so much
i'm a kind of person that wants to check
a box you know i want to like yeah that
appeals yeah i can see that i killed you
as well
yeah
yeah that's good i mean it has always
been of interest to me i mean even when
i was in japan uh you know i spent time
with
i remember passing these monks who would
be
uh what is the expression asking for
alms i mean they would have to do a tour
of duty where they would ask
for money they would have to beg
for their
food if any money to buy food and
so i would always pass these monks uh
not all of them were necessarily zen
buddhist monks but i would pass them
every day as i was walking back from
school when i was 15 as an exchange
student in japan
and have spent a lot of time
recognizing that zen is not uniquely
japanese although zen the word that
pronunciation is japanese
is a tradition that predates its
introduction to japan yeah i mean it
came from china right initially like
that it was called chan before yes
something like that i don't know the
character
that was used for that was probably the
same character actually
uh let me just let me look it up it's
probably the same
in mandarin and then zen
in japanese and then korean i guess
that's
somebody could tell me i'm pretty rusty
in my hangar but my
looking at the at the korean i think
it's jan
and then uh we have vietnamese and so on
what i like most about zen is that it
embraces paradox
because
so much of our existence i think is
paradoxical and so much of what we want
and
so many of our conflicting goals can
sort of be
symbolized by
this word paradox that
it's such a fundamental aspect of our
existences but it's so uncomfortable to
look at directly also because it's not
easily
put on a shelf and organized and just
slotted into some category that you can
understand and figure out dude i want
you to have a zen master on your show
why wouldn't you do that like sam's had
some great i'd do that i do you should
have henry on your show man he's amazing
i'd be open to having henry on the show
i mean i think part of it is that i
i don't feel like i am qualified to ask
informed questions about it
he's had a lot of students also that
have dabbled in psychedelics so he has
some good background there as well and
kind of comparing like senior students
that also practice in and do
psychedelics it'd be interesting to draw
some more yeah that could be that could
be yeah and i'm not a
i even though i support a ton of the
science and i'm very involved with the
policy and regulation and all sorts of
aspects of the psychedelic ecosystem
right now
i don't i'm not a hammer looking for
nils i don't think that psychedelic
should panaceas i mean you're on
mushrooms right now
[Music]
you know it wouldn't be out of character
for that to be the case but i'm not i'm
not on my you're just casually chewing
in the background just like yeah just
just chomping on some mushrooms like
trail mix
uh no no i'm on the i'm on the hard
kombucha kick right now but the i would
love to have somebody on i'd be open to
that i think that would be a really
fascinating conversation because you are
i mean you have such a great background
in all things japanese and obviously you
know the the kind of whole the whole
space with psychedelics and japan all
these things that they're all
interconnected in some way you know yeah
yeah they're definitely interconnected i
mean i and also
i don't view
these tools as
mutually exclusive
right and i was listening to an
interview recently
with dennis mckenna
who i'm gonna have on the podcast soon
dennis mckenna is the younger brother of
terence mckenna who is considered the
irish bard of psychedelics very very
smart guy incredible storyteller dennis
is more of the scientist and the
the
ethnopharmacologist uh phytochemist
of the two he's very scientifically
literate and understands
organic chemistry and synthesis and
things like this
and you know one of the points that he's
made
and did make in this interview i heard
was our experience of reality
is mediated through chemistry and
neurotransmitters so when you hear
people talk about
say getting to certain states naturally
and arguing that is better than
augmenting or using psychedelics
the argument rings somewhat hollow when
you really start to
dig underneath it
and that's not to say that one should
not develop
self-directed capabilities without the
use of drugs or plants to achieve these
states i'm not saying that
but the fact is when you
practice something like if unless we're
gonna go into transpersonal psychology
and some really gnarly terrain which i
could do but
what we're talking about is an
experience of reality which is a
hallucination that we are creating as
the mind sort of applies filters to
incoming information
to optimize for a few things like
propagation of the species
and when you enter in a non-ordinary
state of reality whether it is through
ingesting
say
four or five grams of dried mushrooms
in the case of philosophy mushrooms
psilocybin containing mushrooms or
doing very dedicated zen practice like
you are changing
the cocktail 100
and
in that respect they're actually very
close cousins
although you know certainly some
compounds and plants i think are are
better for achieving
states similar to
you know satori okinsho maybe than
others like meth probably not right
i don't think that uh anyone's going to
suggest meth for for coming to terms
with some of these
deeper realizations necessarily
but there's more i think there's more
common ground than not yeah at least for
those who make a really deep study of it
like like like dennis as an example who
i really encourage everyone to check out
very very bright guy
and uh i'd love to have him on
i think it'd be great henry yeah henry
schickmann yeah he's done a couple q and
a's with sam sam has him creating a lot
of content for sam harris's uh
meditation app so he has a whole
dedicated zen section in there but
yeah i think you'll find him fascinating
because he's also really well versed in
all the latest science and studies going
on and especially some of the
neurosciences happening around the study
of emptiness
which is uh this kind of like
henry can speak to it but it is like the
state like that kencho state of of no
thing like the non-existence
yeah mushin
so i i think you guys would hit it off
it'd be fun i would be very interested i
think mostly and maybe this wouldn't be
the case with henry i mean sometimes you
can get into kind of dangerous pop
science territory
unless you're talking to someone like
adam gazzali right who is there
how the hell does he say it's like it's
all like yeah yeah
side note who got crazy treatment
somewhere in the middle east because of
his last name did he tell you the story
no yeah yeah there's a
sort of iconic figure in i don't want it
i want to say persian but it could have
been actually in saudi arabia somewhere
in middle eastern
culture and history was gazali
g-h-a-z-a-l-i
and they saw his name and he landed the
airport and they're like are you adam
gazelli and he's like yes oh my god oh
you don't need to wait in this line sir
like you come with us and he was like uh
what is it gonna be really awesome or
really bad like really really bad yeah
so adam gazzalli gazghazali we're like
wow i should know this after decades and
none other guy but
is a world-class neuroscientist right so
speaking to him about science is one
thing i would be most interested with
henry to just talk about his personal
experience and to see
how well he can describe
his personal experience like look for me
it's like either
like you gotta choose one end of the
poll or the other it's gotta be like
randomized controlled
studies or personal experience right
both of those i'm very open to it's the
stuff in the middle that gets really
wonky yeah and kind of macgyvered and
and hard to defend yeah his descriptions
of enlightenment and waking up and
some of the
the best i've ever heard all right cool
you will you will be blown away and
you'll have so many you could ask him
about the checking questions because he
does that with the students right so
he's
clearing all the students and how many
of them make it that'd be really curious
you know like how are those
are those off limits are those like the
level 29 of scientology where i can't
ask that until like clear about your
heart it's not a scientology type thing
man it's no
i know i'm just saying is that like
protected knowledge where i can't i
don't think so okay and he can always
say i can't tell you yeah also which is
fair like i'm not saying that's
necessarily a bad thing i'm not
comparing what you're doing to
psychology
no disrespect to scientology i know you
guys like to sue people those too
some of my best friends are
scientologists
but
uh
i'm into it man yeah
oh boy
here we go i was just about to make some
scientology comments
kevin
i love you guys kevin hates you guys
it's no i've i studied uh for a while
and uh i thought it was great you know i
had a good time there good good uh
buffet
on sundays oh god all right
here we go into the thunderdome we
entered we're full dead next week
we're about dead next week it was nice
to have you guys uh
so
uh where do we go from here hard to
segue
uh i would be i would be interested
sweet i'll do the introduction yeah yeah
email intro henry and
i'm excited for this one this is that
that'd be cool i'll be into that i mean
it it overlaps with so many of my
interests right yeah
and i'm not averse to it i don't have an
aversion to it uh the word enlightenment
i'm not gonna lie bothers the [ __ ] out
of me you gotta say that then bring that
up that'd be really curious to
yeah yeah it's just like the idea
because it just it creates this
bifurcation between like the
unenlightened and the enlightened and it
kind of creates this priesthood
and i have
some fundamental allergic reaction to
like this intermediate to the divine
yeah if that makes any sense and i'm not
saying that is how it is presented
within zen buddhism but i do see how
that could be used to create power
dynamics that are unhealthy yeah that's
that's one of the things that uh i was
concerned with having grown up in a
religious household
and later you know kind of understanding
that some of what i was told was not
necessarily true
but
uh the reason i'm so attracted to zen
when we were talking about earlier is
just like they ask you it's not about
believing what they say they ask you to
taste it for yourself
that's what they say you know
yeah yeah i dig that that's cool i can
get behind that
uh
awesome man well please make the intro
and then i'll i'll chat with mr henry
what an episode this has been we've had
lightning strikes
we've i almost threw up at the beginning
yeah kevin almost puked in the beginning
technology was taken down by an act of
god
covered a lot of ground here
yeah yeah good times man well it's good
to hang out yeah good to spend some time
together anything else you'd like to to
mention before we before we wrap uh i
asked my wife what we should talk about
on the show and she said how about my
podcast so
i should
i thought that was funny go for it go
for it yeah so uh my wife daria rose
she's a phd neuroscientist uh from ucsf
and she has a fantastic news show called
the daria rose show she's covering some
crazy topics dude like she she has other
scientists on so they can talk science
but she's covering you you should you
should give some some background on
daria for people who who don't know i
mean she has a lot of scientific traits
yeah so you should just maybe explain
that for those who may be first time
yeah well we just talked recently about
adam gazzolly in his lab over at ussf so
she worked with adam
and yeah so she's uh
got her phd from there in neuroscience
studied stem cell uh biology and
anything above and beyond that is
outside of my pay grade but for her what
she loves to do these days
is really focus on
how to take science and break it down
like things that we can actually trust
and break it down so that the average
consumer can understand it so she has
several episodes on like how can we
trust vaccines why should we trust
vaccines what is what does the science
actually say who should we look for or
to for that information
she's going to be covering like birth
control and what we understand in the
science there a lot of women's issues as
well
how to raise like children in a
thoughtful way that doesn't damage them
forever she had dr andrew weil on
recently and they talked about how to
trust alternative medicine oh like what
do you know is true out there like
there's just so much bs how do you vet
that how do you vet that stuff so i'm
just like i'm just really proud of her
you know she's just kicking ass doing
she andrew huberman on the show like you
said about the whole episode on sleep so
many great takeaways there but yeah
she's done a
great job and um yeah daria road show
yeah daria is
very legit and very very smart very good
at translating without dumbing down yeah
also which
is very hard to do
it is very hard to translate without
dumbing down
and uh she does a great job of that and
uh miss dardar yeah we need to get
together dude
please give hugs to
daria and people definitely check it out
anything else that's it dude you can
find me at uh kevin rose on twitter
modern dot finance is the podcast or i
shouldn't say dot it's called modern
finance but if you want to go the
website it's modern dot finance on the
web
and uh yeah dude thanks for having me on
this was fun as always
yeah man super super fun and uh yeah for
me i don't have much to say you can find
me on tim.log everything i do is there
twitter at t ferris two rs2s
i am ferris timbers on instagram yeah at
tim timcoin is the new coin
i'm gonna launch that i think i'm gonna
do a solano coin can i watch the
cryptocurrency under your name
please it's called coin
oh that'd be that'd be really great for
my liability
[Laughter]
just what i want to think about is i'm
going to bed by the way
just launched two minutes ago 11 12 p.m
tim tim
don't worry about it i'll take care of
it yeah i'll put a ton in your wallet
you'll be good oh what a mess what a
mess yeah i won't do that but i may do i
may do something you should do an nft
dude you really should yeah i mean why
not right i mean like people don't have
to buy it it's like you if you
understand it's a speculative experiment
and i'm doing something weird to learn
more about yeah why not i definitely bid
on your your first smashed body part tim
talk talk
episode
one
all right kev kev well it's good to see
you man brother good chatting and uh to
everybody listening you'll be able to
find show notes links to everything all
the companies books compounds
god knows what yeah that we mentioned
japanese terms sorry show notes friend
uh you'll be able to find it at
tim.blogforslash podcast and until next
time thanks for tuning in
you